It says press enter key, but it's wrong.
It's supposed to be press start.
Oh!
There we go!
Yay!
Woo!
Round zebras.
Hello.
Glad your expo meet and greet went well.
Few things make me happier to see my friends.
Gosh.
Wait.
Gosh what?
Oh.
What am I?
My name?
Gosh about meeting their Oshi.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
It's been a busy day for me already.
I earlier had a meet and greet at Sakura-kun.
Sakura-kun!
I'm here!
And um... Uh... Clay!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Um... And then I...
Impromptu went around Anime Ottawa.
DMCV today.
Yes... Yes... Wait.
No.
DMCV yesterday.
MGSV today.
It is the peak.
Week of peak.
Yeah.
I'm all over the world.
Grugamash.
It was fun though.
It was fun.
I always love doing meet and greets.
So... But the... The iPad at Anime Ottawa was impromptu.
Like... Maybe like an hour or two before my meet and greet at Sakura-kun.
Some off-kai staff messaged me and they're like...
Do you wanna go around on the iPad?
I was like... Yeah!
Yeah!
I wanna do that!
And then they were taking me around.
They were just like... Okay we're headed to the artist alley.
And I was like...
I thought there was a fire there.
And they're like...
Oh!
That's...
In a different country.
I was like...
Where am I?
Wait.
What do you mean a different country?
I didn't even know where I was.
You were just at Anime Ottawa.
I know!
I was the goober in the fauna hat.
Mike!
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
My voice is kind of dead today.
It seems.
Hold on.
I'm gonna have...
Let me have some...
Maybe too much talking today.
Too much talking.
Where are we?
I don't know!
Hold on.
I have two.
Yeah!
I need a Google Maps.
Any more con visits in the future?
Sure.
I'd love to.
I can't say I have any more right now, though.
Look out!
Thank you so much for the attack.
Thank you.
Minto, voice crack you.
No!
I was there in Sakura-kan.
I was wearing all white.
You're the best...
Best, Minto.
Wearing all white?
Were you...
The one that made the...
The wisp?
Sheet?
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
That?
Hi, Minto.
Hello, hello, hello!
Hello, hello, wow.
But yeah, so...
So it was, uh...
It was busy.
And now...
We're playing...
Ground Zeroes.
And your goals!
Thank you so much for the 20 games.
Thank you!
It's always fun seeing you play MDS.
I love Ground Zeroes.
It's so fun, actually.
So excited to send over Supo on my birthday!
City Beast, happy birthday!
Thank you so much for all the...
For all your funny and awesome playthroughs of the Metal Gear series.
Thank you!
In terms of playthrough, the way it looks, the way it plays... Oh my gosh, I say this all the time, but... It truly feels like it could have come out, like... Three years ago.
Like, it's so... If you play any... If you're not interested in story at all, but you want to play Metal Gear... Play at least, like, Grounds... Oh my gosh, it plays so stinking good.
Everything is so clean.
I know!
These games actually play so well.
Like, they're just so fun to play, actually.
So... 2014 was like five years ago.
Yeah!
It shocks me how few games play like it.
It's just... It's actually crazy that this game is ten years old.
Like, it's so... Wow!
Over ten years old!
So... What, three was a great birthday gift yesterday?
I mean, though...
Happy birthday!
Thank you for streaming so badly.
Oh, wait!
Oh, we have two more birthdays.
One more time!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Red!
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, A.G.
Aragorn.
Happy birthday to you.
Wow, one more time.
Happy birthday, dear Christopher.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY to you!
Happy birthday.
Wow, I don't think I've ever done a triple key change before.
That's a new record, I'd say.
It's not my birthday, but Wrestlemania's today, so I'll celebrate that.
But yeah, you're still watching the wrestles.
Three months?
How?
Thank you for three months, Salkin!
Thank you.
So you're saying people should play V if they haven't even played anything else?
Don't get it twisted.
I'm saying if you don't care about the story and all you want to do is play a fun game...
Play V.
I mean, the other games are fun too, but these play... I mean, these are really unique.
These don't play like any of the other Metal Gear games at all.
Get it twisted.
No!
Don't get it twisted.
Don't... don't... don't... don't clip it out of context and have... and cut my words that makes me say...
Play Metal Gear Solid V first.
Because I don't... would not ever say that.
It's also pretty crazy long.
Oh my god!
It is cra...
Five is very long.
Thank you for streaming, Mint.
I have a stomach flu.
Oh no, feel better, Okami!
M'lady Mint.
Thou art a tempest most divine.
Might I, a lowly wretch, bask beneath...
Nope, I'm not reading the rest of that.
Denied!
It was so eloquent though.
I played Ground Zeroes first time in a week ago.
Started playing Phantom Pain, I'm so excited.
Woo, let's go!
About to get so bent and watch this whole stream.
I love MGS.
Yay!
Yippee!
I love MGS too.
I mean, also.
I mean, I also love MGS too.
But, um...
Yeah, so...
So, you might notice also my completion ratio is 18%.
That's because today I intend on playing the original, like the main mission.
The reason we're here.
To continue the story.
Which I'm kind of like...
Do I play the main mission last?
Because after we play the main mission...
I would also like to play...
Uh, this one.
Which you'll...
You will know.
And then...
I've actually never have played Deja Vu.
So it will be my first time actually playing Deja Vu.
Mission.
And then also this, uh, very...
Mysterious character.
That's...
That doesn't look like Snake at all.
Who could that be?
So...
Oh my gosh.
Another birthday.
It's my friend Mari's birthday.
And she's in stream.
I hope you can say her happy birthday.
I will.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mari.
I see you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Well yeah.
So that's what I want to do today.
Um...
So...
If you were just gonna be like...
Oh...
She's gotta get all the patches.
I already did.
I already did that.
And then these ones we don't really have to do.
You know?
Um...
This one...
This one we don't have to do.
I also already took these guys home.
So I will have them in...
And if you...
If you...
If you instead of assassinating them...
Um...
If you steal them...
Then...
You get to have them.
Why...
Why was that guy staring at me?
Did you see that?
The...
The guy right there?
Why were they staring at me?
When do we get the side mission of opening Ka's Burger Shop?
We're not there yet!
It was nice saying hi at the meeting earlier.
I was the one with the gunplay case.
Oh yeah yeah yeah!
I'm gonna treasure the checky.
Thank you.
You were dripped out.
So...
Minto likes MGS.
She also likes MGS2 too.
A good part of MGS2 takes place on April 30th.
April 30th is in a few days.
April 30th was in DMC5.
Which Minto also played yesterday.
Kojima predicted it all!
Truth?
Okay.
Shall we get started?
On Ground Zeroes.
I feel...
Like I said, I feel kind of weird doing this.
Because Ground Zeroes mission is kind of heavy compared to the other missions.
Um, but we'll, we'll, we'll have, we'll get all the sad stuff out of the way.
And then we'll finish it off with some, uh, some, uh, silliness.
Yeah.
Even though I fa...
Just found the VTuber community about a year ago.
You've definitely become my favorite.
Whoa!
Thank you, Dreadnought.
Thank you.
I'm iNerd.
Play Deja Vu mission.
Oh my gosh!
Lambda!
Don't send so much!
I...
I literally said I was gonna play it!
I literally said!
Anyway.
Let's go.
There we go!
Hot dog!
Every time I ask this...
If this N5 is canon, I get it's complicated.
What do you...
What?
Yes!
Why would anybody say that this game is not canon?
What?
No.
This...
This game and N5 are canon, huh?
I think that's not...
Oh!
I don't think that is...
Is disputed amongst fans, is it?
I don't think...
I don't think that's disputed.
Okay!
Thank you so much for the 5gripton.
I know people say that about like portable ops, but...
These two games are 100% canon.
Yeah...
Huh.
Um...
Oh.
Uh, these...
These like...
Okay, maybe we...
Wait.
Okay, hold on.
Oh.
In an era when the world was still divided into East and West.
The boss, the mother of special...
Oh, I think this is just a recap.
Yeah.
This is all just a recap.
Well, don't worry.
There are actual cutscenes, so...
We'll start.
It's been a long time since I've watched these cutscenes, actually.
Thank god there aren't dogs in this game.
Like, actually...
Who's this guy?
Who is this guy?
Everybody else has like their little ponchos on.
Oh, he lost his hat!
A child.
Whoa.
See that?
Did you see that?
Did you see it?
He told us everything.
Don't worry.
I kept my word.
He didn't suffer long.
He's got his airpods in.
He can't hear you.
Here.
Bink, bink.
Oh.
You earned it.
The tapes.
Ooh.
How's it feel to play the traitor?
No more wargames.
You're a real man now, soldier.
Tyco!
What do you mean, but...
What do you mean traitor?
What's he listening to?
Drop the mixtape.
Give my regards to your boss when you get home.
Oh, what is that one?
Oh.
This mic...
This will probably get...
Copyright struck, but that's okay.
We'll show this cutscene to show how good the graphics would be in the future.
Still looks amazing.
It looks so good.
Thanks to you, meepola and Bob.
Oh, try princess.
10 days ago, we got reports that Paz was still alive.
She's alive.
She was rescued by a Belizean fisherman who found a drifting in the Caribbean.
So what's the plan?
Silence her before we're compromised?
No.
I've got something else in mind.
Our friends at Cypher suspect Paz could be a double agent.
She's being held for interrogation at a camp on the southern tip of Cuba.
Black Sight.
Nice.
A slice of American pie on communist soil and out of US legal jurisdiction.
It's not David Hayter.
The actual inspection of Mother Base has to be connected somehow.
I know, it's really weird here, Ian.
The time is too perfect.
The UN's nuclear inspection.
He talks more in this game than he doesn't be.
He talks more in this game than Paz is late.
We're an army.
What if our capabilities get us out?
And they'll have the whole world out to shut us down.
Having an American private intelligence agency involved, bad news.
Cypher's the ones who sent Paz to us in the first place.
She knows the true nature.
Right.
Paz is our only link to Cypher.
If she's still alive, we need her on our side.
We need her on our side.
Yeah, he talks more in this...
I didn't realize how much he talked in this cutscene.
He's coherent.
He's...
I mean, after.
It'd be you.
Well, okay.
I'm gonna shut my mouth.
I was gonna say something that spoils the end of this.
But I won't say anything.
I'm not gonna say anything.
Don't say anything.
Don't say anything, guys.
XOF.
Oh.
No spoilers.
Trojan horse.
Look
at that.
Skull face.
It looks like a...
It looks like a lizard.
Like a...
It looks like an actual snake look.
Snake man.
Skull face.
Let's go!
Oh gosh.
These light flares kill me.
My eyes.
He's like, that's what the helicopter does.
Kojima really loves his lens flare.
The lens flare in this game is so iconic that you can, like, get mods for it in other games.
So who's the other target?
That would be Chico.
Chico!
Being held in the same area as Paz.
Well, take off your patches.
The last radio contact was 40 hours ago.
Take off your patches.
Bring him back alive.
That guy is ugly.
I don't think that's like a really...
Like...
I don't think that's a reliable way of disposing of them.
I don't know, I could be wrong, but...
Yeah!
We'll send a chopper from across the Cuban border.
You should be back at Mother Base in time for lunch.
Yeah!
You'll probably just miss our guests.
The only catch is, you go and solo.
Of course.
The politically sensitive nature of the mission meets backup is not an option.
Fine.
I like some alone time now and then.
Do I bother with the badges and XOF signs at that point?
I don't know.
You know.
For dramatics.
Oh, sorry, I'm blocking the names.
My head is literally right on top of the credits.
Christopher Randolph.
He
just slowed you down one bit.
Kiefer Sutherland.
He said the thing!
He said it!
I recognized it!
Oh my gosh, it looks so awesome.
I obviously don't want to talk so much about the Kiefer Sutherland, David Hayter... debate... at the moment.
Oh, we got our eye droid!
We can talk a little bit about it.
The eye droid is so cool!
Alright, welcome!
Okay.
Look at this, guys.
I don't think I'll do that, but thank you.
Let's see, let's capture some guys.
Welcome to Ground Zeroes, if this is your first time.
Seeing how the game plays...
Holy, look at this, we get to mark enemies.
Deja Vu Mission, hell yeah!
Yeah!
Thank you, Lefto!
Look at this, look how...
Gosh, I can't ever get over how nice this game looks.
We got that guy!
Is there someone in there?
Nobody in there?
Oh, there's the other man.
I was waiting for him.
Yeah!
It looks so good, no?
Alright, give me a second.
I gotta get used to how things are again.
Oh, I got a sniper.
I got a rocket launcher.
Do I have anything else over here?
No?
Hmm...
They gave us some little goodies.
You think he'll see me?
Let's see.
No, I don't want the night vision.
Let's attach...
Try rolling, I already got the patches.
So, I don't need to roll.
I already got the patches.
Let's see.
Keep low.
You can check the controls on the pause screen.
Thanks, guys!
If you ready your weapon while crawling, you can move horizontally left or right.
If you do that holding the dash button, you'll move faster.
Um, I don't know if I can get this guy.
Let's try.
Ugh.
I don't even know if I'm reaching him.
My eyes!
So, we gotta go grab Chico...
And pause...
Where's our map?
Here we go.
So...
If we're heading that way over there...
Whoa...
Whoa, look how fancy everything is!
Crawl on the ground like the snake you are.
Where'd that other guy go?
Another guy that I...
Oh, there he is.
Oh!
I did get him!
Nah!
I didn't even realize.
He didn't even react.
Okay, nice.
And...
Please.
Oh my gosh.
My controller.
Oh!
There we go.
I didn't even realize I got him!
Let's go.
Better tech in the 70s.
I know!
That's one thing about these games.
It's like the technology regresses so hard.
Oh, he's on his way back.
Oh, maybe not.
This guy is fine too.
Now head east to the old prison area.
Okay.
Bring up the target's location on your eye droid.
Let's make sure.
Are there any people over here?
Oh, there's a guy.
Everybody's sick in this game.
Whoa, mama!
Johnny Bravo!
Yeah.
I tried to help marking them as well, but it only marked you for some reason.
Probably because my binoculars can only see pretty ladies!
Mr. Bravo!
Hold on, I wonder if I can get this guy.
Oh my god, I didn't realize there was a truck coming!
Um, I'm so dead maybe.
Snake, get in the bush!
Okay.
Did I get him?
Maybe I got him.
I don't want to get his light yet.
I don't want them to notice.
I hit the rail?
No way.
I can't tell.
If the first one hit him or not.
No!
I haven't played the main mission in so long, you guys.
Oh.
Let's try.
What enemy?
Enemy has left the area.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
He should fall asleep.
Like, any second.
I'm worried about the second part of this mission.
I can do the first part, not so bad, but...
Oh, the jeep!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stop shining that light in my face, mister.
Oh, there he goes.
Nice.
Wait.
How do I turn my flashlight off?
Wait, how do I...
Yeah, how do I turn it off?
It turned on.
I don't know why.
Wait.
Oh, God!
It got dicey.
Hold...
I'm...
I'm playing!
Hold up d-pad, then press triangle.
Thank you.
Okay.
There we go.
Thank you.
I'm playing with not...
Oh.
There we go.
Please don't say...
JP, this is Zulu...
Zulu 1.
Lied out, and we don't know why.
Someone go investigate.
The snake cake.
It's so real, baby.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, more light.
Okay.
Did I get him?
I can't tell...
Oh.
Thanks, guys.
Guys just backseats his entire way through this game.
He's playing to a Hollywood actor who never played a video game in his life.
The plot of Three and Peace Walker.
I know, right?
He feel asleep?
Hello, Minto.
Hello.
Please go to bed.
Please.
Investigate the Mickey noises.
No!
Wait, hold on.
I know there's some guys over here, right?
Okay.
Let's grab.
No?
Pretty empty.
Ugh!
Spooking.
Please go to sleep!
I'll crawl through the...
The bushes for now.
This guy scares me.
It's directed right where we need to go.
Hate it when there are guys.
I know!
Why can't you like...
Just...
Not exist.
In the game.
Nice shot, thank you.
And then you can do this.
Oh.
Nevermind.
It didn't let me press the triangle.
Contact me if you need advice.
Oh my god!
Even if I don't have anything to say to you, you still...
Kaz loves to hear himself talk.
My man is so lonely.
You think I can get him...
Oh god!
My eyes!
I hear a cough.
How's the audio, by the way, guys?
Please, did I get you?
The light is shining!
It shines so bright!
Please!
It's good?
Okay.
It's like when those cars have LED lights.
And then you have a short car and it's like a...
It's a big truck behind you.
Oh, there we go.
Finally.
Oh, wow!
I got a new record!
Finally!
I'm gonna waste all my tranks on...
I'm gonna waste all my stuff on this guy!
Okay.
Onward.
Hold on.
Is there someone in there?
Oh!
I've never heard...
I don't remember this.
My buddy was crying on my shoulder about it.
But that place has been dead for years.
Now we got these...
I don't know who's bringing in...
My car is low as hell and it blinds me every time.
Oh my god!
I did not see that guy!
I can't adjust...
Oops.
Bad shot.
Good shot.
Let's move you...
Um...
Not here.
Come here.
Come over here.
Let's put you...
In...
Here!
There we go!
Okay!
Now...
I know there's a guy...
No?
Unless it was...
I see that guy in there.
Eepy time!
So eepy sleepy!
Let's check up here.
Also...
For anyone wondering...
I have already gotten all the prisoners.
Like I've already taken them home before.
Except...
One.
But I think I've already missed him anyway.
I still haven't been able to get him before.
There's one...
If you didn't know...
There's one secret guy...
We're kind of close to where we...
Started the game.
That you can get...
You think you can get him?
From here?
Oh, don't move.
Wait, where are you going?
Where are you going?
Okay, nevermind.
That's the old prison area.
Yeah.
The targets are there.
Ooh...
Yeah, but it's okay.
We don't...
We...
Sorry prisoners.
You know, it's just one of those things.
Look at...
He's already sleepy.
And this guy...
Where is he?
I don't think I can get him from here.
I think that's...
I think it's just these two, no?
I think?
Hmm...
Just one of those days...
Yeah...
Eepy sleepy.
Oh...
Let's...
Let's see if we can get him now.
Maybe?
I don't know if I can get him now.
Through here.
Let's try.
I might be able to be...
Oh...
I think I got him.
Sort of laundry detergent does MSF use.
Okay.
Now...
We hope he doesn't see this fellow.
You know what?
Hold on.
There we go.
Now he won't see that fellow.
And there's no one up there.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Oh wait.
Uh...
Return to the sea!
This guy, too.
Actually...
Are there rocks down there?
I don't think I heard a splash.
Uh...
Return to the sea!
Yay!
There he goes.
I didn't hear a splash before.
Yeah, I heard a splat.
Sorry, guy.
Chico!
Are you Chico?
Chico?
No?
Okay.
He's shaking his head.
Are you Chico?
I know where he is.
Oh, he's counting.
He's trying to stay sane.
I don't think that's Chico.
Oh.
We like to play the special piece.
Are you Chico?
Anyway.
You must be Ames.
The jump in tone from Peace Walker to this game is always wild to me.
It's like if the Dark Knight took place right after Adam West.
I know!
Oh.
Here we go.
Chico.
Look me in the eyes.
It is true though.
The tone of whiplash is absolutely insane.
Sorry, everybody else.
Chico.
Chico, it's me.
Hey.
Go away!
Hey!
Shh!
Everybody shut up!
Everybody, shh!
Get off!
Chico, keep it down.
Go away!
Tranquilize him!
Right over here.
Hey.
Hey, you gotta let me out.
Hey!
Oh, I'm not gonna take any of you guys if you don't... Shut up!
Knock him out.
Punch him in the face.
Oh.
Choke him.
Chico, calm down.
I don't think that's gonna help him calm down.
Calm down.
Shh.
Eternal rest.
Aww, little Chico.
Little baby boy.
Did they just give off or something?
Not here.
Are you sure?
Pretty sure.
Is Chico able to walk?
Uh...
He might have been before.
Lambda.
Chico!
Hi.
Alright.
We got Chico.
Sorry, everybody else.
So sorry.
Sorry.
I saved you before in another timeline.
Trust.
Believe me.
Okay.
Chico?
Stop coughing.
Why?
Chico, shh.
Chico, I need you to shut up, please.
Chico, stop.
Stop making noise.
Alright.
You got a friend, huh?
Wait.
Let's reload.
No, wait.
Oh, he...
They're like staring straight at each other.
Hmm.
Okay, hold on.
Now I can do this.
Maybe.
That was not good.
Hahaha.
Stop.
There we go.
Alright.
Chico, come on.
We're going to the rendezvous point.
Which is all the way down there.
Okay.
Okay, buddy.
Alright.
What?
What you don't end up head first in the ocean.
Oops.
Sorry, Chico.
No.
You can now either interrogate him, knock him out, or kill him.
His life is in your hands.
Look at some ammo.
Thank you.
Feed him to the fishes?
Yeah.
You're going to the fishes.
There's a guy up there, so we gotta be a little bit careful.
You're going to the fishes!
Watch this, Chico.
Hahaha.
Watch this.
Watch that.
Did you like it?
Chico.
Chico, this will be you one day.
Well, no.
Like, you will be the one throwing them in one day.
You'll take after me.
Look, Chico.
Watch and learn.
It doesn't count as a kill.
I don't know, actually, if it counts as a kill or not.
I...
It's not my fault if they don't know how to swim.
Okay?
Hit some ammo here.
Never mind.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Never mind.
Let's go!
Yeah, that one hit the rocks a little bit.
It was a bit of a...
Rocky.
Way down.
If gravity killed them, then you're innocent.
Yeah!
Return Chico to the sea.
What about pause?
What?
What are you saying?
Don't resist.
Don't resist, buddy.
I'm gonna put you in the cave.
Chico...
I'm so sorry.
Great.
You reached the RV.
Put the target down for a minute.
How's he doing?
Chico, where's Paz?
Just like Chico.
Too...
Too real.
The sick tunes.
Why are you just listening to that?
She's dead.
I don't understand why he's listening to it, though.
Keeper better than Snake is a joke.
Okay, now use your eye droid to call the chopper for pick-up.
Um...
I'm gonna wait on that real quick.
Instead...
Chico's tape.
Wait...
Which one is it?
What's the one we just got?
Oh my god, there's so many pause reports.
Holy cow!
It was three?
Thank ya.
Oh, oh yeah!
This isn't Duran Duran.
Yeah, we can probably listen to the Paz tapes later.
Chico was taken out of his cage.
Did he leave the tape recording while he was being moved?
Hmm...
Paz might be up ahead.
I don't typically like listening to the tapes while I'm playing because it distracts me, but...
Vehicles.
How astute.
Astute observation.
Kazuhiro Miller.
Is that...
A helicopter.
Of some...
Another vehicle.
Must be near the heliport.
Okay.
I don't think Paz is dead.
Is it from Japan?
A gate.
Well, lucky for them, I know exactly where she's at.
Pretty high quality recording for a portable recorder in 1974.
Look.
Things were just built different in that era, you know?
I wish I could get more ammo.
I might have to start being lethal.
Hehehehe.
What was it?
Chico left the tape on record while he was being moved.
Try using what you hear to find Paz.
If you're still not sure, listen to the tape again.
Listen to the whole tapes after this boss.
I...I don't want to listen to them while I'm playing.
Cause like I said, it distracts me.
But I...
Will listen to some of them at least.
Oh, hello mister.
Oh, he's sick.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
I did not see that guy there.
Whew.
That was close.
Holy cow.
My bad.
Um...
I can just hide you right here.
I guess.
Nice save, thank you.
Golly.
Okay, they're just having like a little...
Special bonding moment together.
Nobody up there, it seems.
Okay, now here's the part of the game that...
Well, no, we're not quite there yet.
The part I'm not very good at is coming up.
Okay.
Yeah.
Next they headed for a place with a helicopter.
I see that guy by the way.
I see him.
Hello.
He's like looking right at me.
Oh.
He looks so wistful.
Bless you!
He looks so...
Okay.
Is anybody in here?
Uh oh.
Please no.
What?
You!
I know!
Oh my god.
He sees me so easily.
You heard me say bless you.
Yeah.
I'm just trying to be polite.
It's fine.
We got his ass.
Who else is around you?
There's a security camera like right over there.
Oh, you can hear it.
You hear it?
Hehehe.
Uh, oop.
I see you.
Oh, I see you.
Okay.
Surveillance camera.
I mean...
There's only like 40 guys on this base.
We could just kill them all.
No?
Look, I'm putting...
Oh, whoops.
I'm putting you out of the rain.
So that, you know, you...
Are...
You don't get sick.
I'm actually quite considerate, no?
Hehehehe.
I'm quite considerate.
I'd say.
Okay.
How do we...
Um, go around these guys?
That's a good question.
What?
It's also stealth that there's no witnesses.
Hehehehe.
Yeah.
This guy might be kinda risky.
But...
We'll still try for it.
I don't think he turns around.
Does he?
Everybody?
Everybody's sick here.
It's because you forced them outside in the rain.
So nice of you.
That's why you're the best boss.
I would do the same for you guys, you know?
The surveillance camera.
Oh.
There's a guy right there too.
Goodnight.
I don't wanna grab him.
No.
Oh, there.
Hehehehe.
He said it.
Oh, he got some grenades.
Oh, that's the rocket launcher.
Okay, never mind.
And everything.
Why isn't the camera picking up the guy collapse?
Don't worry about it.
Would you also force us in the rain?
Um...
I mean, actually, you can come over here.
No?
You're not gonna do that?
He's just like...
I think I saw something weird.
He's like...
I'm...
This is above my pay grid.
To investigate.
Honestly.
I'm gonna go through here.
I know.
You might be able to crawl in there.
Thanks in advance for dragging us to a dry place after you shoot us.
Yeah, of course.
Look at the little rat.
Bless you.
I hate doing the cover attack because it uses too many of my fingers.
I wonder if I could get him without the other guy noticing.
You know?
That's one thing.
That's...
I could drag him.
Get more fingers.
True.
Never mind.
I don't need to get him at all.
That's the admin building.
Watch your corners.
Okay.
Thanks, guys.
I don't remember who's around in here.
I hear another surveillance.
Wait, who?
What?
No way.
That guy saw me through the door.
I hate this game.
Is he still seeing me?
Yes, he is.
This guy sucks.
No way.
No way!
Oh, never mind.
He doesn't see.
What are you doing?
Oh, he went inside.
What is...
What is he doing?
What's my gun doing?
What's going on?
Oh, my gun is jorking it.
For real.
Okay, he's leaving, good.
I got it.
Okay.
As soon as I shoot this surveillance...
Actually, do I need to?
Is there another guy over there?
Or...
I might not need to.
Is there someone up here?
No?
Uh-oh.
CP, this is Zula 2.
Zula 2.
Oh, no.
Go, go, go!
Even in ground, there must be wary of doorknobs.
Holy cow, that scared me.
Whoa!
That guy freaked me out.
Oh, there's two of them!
No contact.
Yep.
Oh, come on.
There we go.
No contact?
What are you talking about contact?
Excellent save, boss.
Thank you.
I don't know if there's anybody in here or not.
Wait.
Do I see feet?
Doesn't seem like anybody.
What's that?
These other guards collapse unconscious and a shadowy figure crawling around.
Nope.
Way above my pay grade.
She looks so bad.
Oh, my God.
There's a dog barking outside.
He's so loud.
Buzz!
Oh, my gosh.
Her luscious locks.
I know.
Oh, sweet baby girl.
Oh, my gosh.
I never realized that I played...
Maybe I just forgot that it plays...
Love the turrets there.
Okay.
Come on.
Yes.
I don't remember if...
New guys come, or if these guys were the guys...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
No, no, no, no.
Uh...
Oh, shit!
I did the wrong thing.
Uh...
Nope, nope.
Um...
This is the part I'm bad at.
Spit it out.
Oh, God!
There's more coming!
Ah, there's more coming!
Oh, uh...
Uh, you know what?
Shoot to kill.
These guys suck, anyway.
Okay.
Come on, Pies.
Sorry.
No, a minus two.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
It's okay, we'll get you some Pepto Bismol, girly.
Oh.
Uh... You know what?
This might be a bad idea, but...
No!
I don't know who's closest.
Nobody is.
Oh, there's a guy there.
Uh... Shh, shh, shh, shh.
Actually, uh...
Maybe I can...
get him.
Shoot!
Got him.
I love reaction time!
Yeah!
Okay, come on.
I can't believe I missed the first one.
Okay, let's keep going.
I know some... Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Okay, this is where...
Ah!
Oh, golly.
Get and call the chopper.
Keep an eye out for nearby enemies.
They can try to shoot down the chopper.
I'm gonna take her...
Well, also, we gotta take her to...
We gotta take her to, uh...
Chico.
Might be better to just run for it.
Oh, gosh.
No, I thought you were gonna keep running!
Why'd you stop?
No!
Uh-oh.
He's definitely gonna see me.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I can get him.
Okay.
Oh, there's another guy right there!
No!
Happy birthday!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, no.
I need to...
I need to pay attention.
Sorry.
Happy birthday!
Oh, shoot.
I need to get this guy.
It's about to start being lethal time soon.
Right.
Oh, my God.
Where are all these guys coming from?
Ah!
Uh, this might be where we...
Die, everybody.
Ah!
No!
Don't die!
Ah!
Oh,
this is the part that I get all scared at.
It's okay.
The checkpoint was right here, so...
Go ahead and call the chopper.
Keep an eye out for nearby enemies.
They can try to shoot down the chopper.
You!
You son of a gun!
Oh, wait.
I just realized the, uh...
What's it called is...
Is active.
You see that tank right there?
Oops.
I know I got him, but I kinda want him to go down.
Um...
We don't want the tank to, like...
To wake up.
At us, you know?
We don't want the tank to, like, shoot at us.
That would be, like, so bad.
Or we don't want the spotlight to see us.
Oh my god.
That guy sees us.
Oh, I think he just fell asleep.
Perfect.
We're just gonna do a little sprint.
A little sprint.
And...
So far, so good.
There's a guy right there, but I think we're okay.
Uh, I think, actually, we're okay.
We're gonna sprint?
We're gonna go?
Come on, Jake.
Come on.
What do you mean?
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait.
No, shoot.
Shoot, please.
Shoot.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Where did you come from?
Oh my god, where did you guys come from?
Where?
Oh, shoot, where?
Wait, where?
Where?
From when?
From where?
Where?
Wait, actually, where?
Oh my god.
Ah!
The tank!
Boss!
I'm sorry!
Sorry.
Don't yell.
You think she's okay up there?
What are they firing at?
It's not her, right?
Oh.
Contact?
Where?
Oh, oh shit.
Ah!
Don't yell!
No, you come over here.
You come over here!
Get out of there.
That guy is just walking.
No, you're okay!
You might not be okay.
Can they see me?
Death 2?
CP, this is Zulu 6.
Hostel gun out of sight.
Searching now.
Over.
This is CP.
Understood.
Search every corner.
They gotta be around here somewhere.
Out.
Is he behind the rock?
Oh, he must be.
Oh, yeah.
They're...
Um...
They'll...
They'll leave eventually.
No urgency.
I know.
Oh my god.
There's still...
There's that guy.
I didn't even see him.
Maybe I'll rush them.
How did you see me?
Chico?
Uh...
I'm sorry.
It's not me.
Ouch!
Don't worry, Chico!
Oh, that wasn't just for that one stinking guy!
I didn't see him on my way to...
Wait, where am I?
Uh...
No way!
Shut up.
Whoops.
Shut up, shut up, shut up!
Ma'am.
Nice spawn.
I didn't even realize...
Oh my god.
They won't see me, right?
Drop down.
They're gonna notice she's missing at some point.
Oh boy.
Ugh!
Be gentle with her.
There's no time!
See, pain is an illusion.
Pain...
Pain is in...
Oh my god.
We're so doomed.
This is so...
Shit!
Why are there two cars?
Is he gonna see me?
No way.
Where did this other car come from?!
You son of a bitch!
Oh my god, I can't see.
Um...
Please.
I missed.
Nooooo!
Wait...
Hostel!
Stop it!
Oh my god.
I'm just making the most noise ever.
Please, guy.
Please.
There we go.
I need to go before the...
The car comes, you know?
We need to go before the car comes.
Alright.
Now we'll put her in the bushes.
Right here.
And I'll get these guys.
Hopefully.
Oh my god.
No stinking way.
Okay.
And...
Round three.
This is...
This is fine.
This guy is nothing.
This guy is whatever.
Who cares?
Pull it...
Oh.
Wait.
I think he's down.
Okay!
Everything's fine.
Guys!
I don't know even where that guy went.
There's no one else over here, right?
You're okay, Pies.
You're okay, little baby.
Great shot on the driver.
Thank you!
Oh!
Oh my god!
I was like, I think there's a guy down there.
But I couldn't remember.
The chopper.
The chopper...
You're together!
You remember each other?
Oh, sorry.
They're like kind of...
Fused together at this moment.
Like a freaky...
Oh.
Oh my god.
Anyway, okay.
Let's call the chopper.
Did he just say sorry?
Is he talking to her?
Wait, she's humming.
Love the turrets.
That's so sad.
I didn't know that she did that.
Oh, my babies.
Sorry, I keep walking on top of them.
Sorry.
Morpho.
Thank you.
I didn't know she helped that.
It's so sweet.
All right.
Who did I pick up?
Chico, you're first.
Yeah, P-Quad will be for next game.
For obvious reasons.
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
Me too.
I want to go in.
All right, get in.
Time to go.
Yay!
Are you still upset with Poz before hearing your tapes?
I was never upset with Poz.
First try.
I told you the second half would be kind of rough.
But... We made it.
We made it.
Oh.
Oh, boy.
What do you think?
Oh.
I was gonna say, what do you think my red kiss?
Then I turned my head.
You could see it.
Me for Poz.
Me for Boo.
Yeah, yeah.
Two kill.
Minus 400.
I would have gotten...
Three retrives.
Okay.
You guys ready for the cutscene that leads into five?
Are you guys ready?
I'm not ready.
Me for Boomer.
It's okay.
Because after this, we'll play some silly missions and they're fun.
I don't know how he picks him up.
She's weak.
Damn it, we were set up.
We gotta get it out.
She set her stomach.
We have to open her now.
No time for our aesthetic.
We gotta open her now.
Hold her down.
Hold her down!
Oh.
You have...
Oh, wait.
Ah, wait.
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh.
Ah, sorry.
I forgot that there...
Oh.
So sorry.
Ah!
I'm Chico.
I don't think I ever watched this part.
Actually, myself.
Protect us, Minto.
I'm protecting your eyes, but not my eyes!
Eww!
Oh, God!
AHHHH!
Keep the gun in!
Breathing stable.
No action bleeding.
Closing her up.
She's clean!
It's gotta be a continuous shoot.
A call.
Close, can you hear me?
What's up, Huey?
Our guests are right on time.
Document destruction and hangar decontamination are complete.
AFVs have been stowed away.
And Zeke's on the sea floor, along with the nuke.
Everyone's got their story straight.
The guided tour is wrapped up by the time you get home.
Sounds good.
Make me proud.
I believe I'll have the IAEA praising us as the poster boys for world peace.
Out.
What?
Guys, I...
Stinky farts?
My cat?
Yeah, she just had a bit of explosive indigestion.
Tower, this is Morpho 1.
I winked, but you couldn't tell.
Can't get through.
The lake seems fine, but...
Oh my gosh, wait.
It's really cloudy today.
Oh!
MSF?
Look
at, they're out there fighting!
Guys!
Watch out, Chico!
Save, Leech!
Oh
my god.
I'm here.
Another?
The White Snake.
Yeah, get his ass.
Please.
Guys.
Oh my god.
My whole face.
Oh, it hurts.
It hurts.
Snake's like, no, my man.
Everything.
Everything gone.
Everything's gone.
My hours and peace walk are... gone.
The inspection was nothing but a smoke screen.
I heard explosions.
They played us like a damn fiddle.
Give it back.
Sorry.
This isn't right.
That was ours.
We built it, damn it.
We did.
Spying bitch.
Come on.
Start talking, bitch.
Get up and start talking.
Guys, calm down.
Oh god.
How does she have, like, the strength to move?
Bob?
She's leaving it all.
Bob, there's...
It's alright.
We got it out.
There's another...
No!
Can you make my...
Oh my god.
And then another... another helicopter right into ours.
Smoke from the disaster was visible from the coastline.
The media blamed money-minded private militias.
And scandals followed when the US was fingered as one of... one of the organization's top clients.
In response, the Secretary of Defense publicly stated that neither the US nor its allies had any hand.
Reports also suggested that... I-A-E-A.
English inspectors visited the site.
However, the UN and the IAEA instead no such inspection took place.
Oh gosh, sorry.
The casualty figure is uncertain.
There are no known survivors.
However, in the moments prior to and following the incident, several unidentified military cops were sighted in the area.
I-E-I-A-E-I...
XD You're favorite song.
Nicola, Barth, immigrants wrongly executed, but their deaths served as a message to others.
That ours is a society that murders the innocent.
Do you, too, believe your sacrifice will change the world?
Ah, you're right, Jordan.
Ugh.
Yeah, PeaceWalker.
That's why I'm just like, you can't play this game in V without, like, PeaceWalker.
Because you just don't feel... You don't feel it!
You don't feel that pain.
Ugh.
Don't work!
The loss.
It hurts so bad!
Oh, it hurts!
Ugh!
Everything you built up!
All those men you captured!
Everybody that you... You read their little bios and you become accustomed and... And... And...
Uh... And... You grow close.
You just want their little... You just look at their little faces and you're like, That's my team!
That's MSF!
Their little personalities!
All of them gone!
Oh, my man!
I love them so much!
The moment is yours.
The agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Mark.
The last and final moment is yours.
The agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, I love them all.
Are you sure those were your men?
I didn't see anyone running around in T-shirts.
Oh, my God!
They were all gone!
Ugh!
Me coming into this part of the stream makes me feel like that one guy with the pieces.
So...
That's, like, the intro into V.
I think there's a little bit after the credits, no?
I mean, there usually is.
They played us like a damn fiddle!
Oh, my gosh, Akira, you said that at the same time that I was just thinking it.
But, uh...
Yeah, that's the intro to V.
Leech.
And, um...
But...
We're gonna do some of the side...
Um, extra...
The side-offs are...
More fun.
So...
Um...
You know...
We just watched Paws explode...
And everything fall apart in front of us.
But now we can play as silly things!
Uh...
Possible watch the V trailers.
Mm...
Why?
Uh...
Been trying to play the games as you play them since I never had the opportunity before after gaming with the Unpeace Walker.
I played through Ground Zeroes for the first time yesterday.
Yeah... It sucks.
They were good trailers.
Yeah, but I want to get through the missions before we do anything else.
Meanwhile, myself, Big Mac, Brooks, and Mobius are on co-op mission.
Zoological guard.
Animal coordinator.
Animal trainer.
Motion actor?
Blue rats motion actor.
But, um... Yeah, this is basically how... How... V plays, but with like some...
Some... A little bit of... A little bit of upgrades.
It's pretty much the same.
The rat actors.
Rat vocal beat.
Yeah, very slight differences.
Why does she keep calling it V instead of 5?
Because it's technically V.
It's either way, but like...
It's supposed to be...
The, the, um, the, um, actually term is V.
But
yeah...
If you want to, um, actually people.
V has come too.
I don't know why... It annoys you though.
Now imagine waiting for V after this came out.
Right!
Actually...
Like a year?
Maybe?
I
need to replay MGS3 remake.
I want to see how... Well, I played a little bit of it, but...
How would you feel about a spiritual successor?
But in a fantasy world?
Like play...
Play... Wait, huh?
I want to see if people are interested before spending my GMP.
Enchanted lanterns for cameras.
Like play...
Like...
I mean, I think any game that plays like...
This one would be fun.
None of that was my fault.
Leech!
I never blamed you!
Our buddy just accidentally pushed the...
The self destruct button that is on the base, you know?
Oh my god.
The longest credits ever.
Hideo Kojima.
Oh my god.
The longest credits ever.
You can hear it, right?
Yeah.
I've never known choice.
Where I was born.
The language I speak.
Oh boy.
I've never had the freedom to choose for myself.
But you, right now.
Learn a new language, buddy.
It's free.
Do as you will.
Duolingo.
I don't know.
It's just...
This will save...
Big boss.
This guy is such a loser.
It may.
He really is.
Will you...
Really kill...
Zero for me?
Not for you.
Not for honor.
Alright.
Hush.
Zero is...
Oh boy.
Okay.
I'm...
Uh...
I can't...
Oh!
1976.
The Les Enfantes Hubles.
Project is abandoned.
Uh...
Oh, there's so much text.
I give up.
Oh my god!
Dr. Huey Emmerich's first child is born.
His name is Hal.
Wee.
Mucho texto.
Skippa!
To be continued in the Phantompane!
Phantompane!
But, this is not the end of the stream.
So, we got more to play.
Boss!
I mean, oh my god!
I mean, he took a huge hit of the bomb.
He was right there.
Deceived.
And left for dead.
Visage?
Is this...
Deprived of all but pain.
He's gonna say it.
I'm afraid it's been...
Nine years.
Only one thing remains.
Just to suffer!
Retribution!
Diamond dogs!
Shoot the children!
Oh my god.
I can't take it seriously.
Me neither.
Why are we here?
Just to suffer.
Yeah, that's a Metal Gear reference.
Yeah!
Oh, that's my controller.
Sorry.
Wait, let me reconnect it.
The children had it coming.
No spoilers!
It's literally in the trailer.
That is actually in the trailer.
That is not a spoiler.
Sorry, I swallowed my T-Rog.
You guys wanna hear something so sad after that too?
That was the OG Vine meme?
Actually, is it this one?
Yeah.
That was the OG Vine meme?
Was it a Vine meme?
It's so sad.
Love the torrents.
F them kids.
Why is his shadow balding?
Oh my god, you're right.
Look at his shadow.
He's got no hair.
Boss, where's your hair at?
I thought about putting this on when I was getting paused, but I was like, I'm too scared.
I'm going to get spotted.
Foreshadowing.
Don't say that.
And then there's Heaven's Divide.
What's this one?
Is this one just the actual song?
Oh.
No, it's like also like a... orchestral version.
Oh god, it's so loud.
What else we got?
Of course, Ride of the Valor...
We got Grease for some reason.
I don't quite understand why this is on here.
Internet.
What else we got on here?
Pauze's Diary Entries.
There's so many of them.
Wait, how long are they?
I can't remember.
Do we want to...
Let's play some more missions first, and then we can listen.
Listen.
Because I want to do...
Richard Wagner, my favorite MGS composer.
I want to do...
Is it this one?
Yeah.
I want to do this one.
Because this one's silly.
And then...
This one.
And then this one.
So let's do this one first.
So...
The mother base agent undercover at the prison facility has signaled for immediate evac.
Secure the agent and escape the mission area by chopper.
Apocalypse now movie reference.
Oh.
I guess that makes sense.
I droid play invisible.
No!
But...
I don't know what I'm going to have my chopper.
What...
What I will make the song be when it picks us up.
We got a request for extraction from a member of the intel team who is working undercover at the prison.
As you know, it's an enemy.
With three!
With no time for the silent approach.
Assault the base.
Where?
Get out of there.
The target is our agent from the intel team.
J.F.
Ray Eyewin.
The base of particle VIP would be a massive underdainment.
Fancy.
Bring
him home, boss.
Got it.
Where's our guy?
Where is everybody?
This base is empty.
Hello?
Anybody here?
I'm trying.
There's nobody here.
Oh.
Where'd that guy go?
I just lost him.
Where'd he go?
Wait.
Where'd...
Where'd that guy go?
Where'd he go?
Damn it.
Where is he?
Where?
11 o'clock.
What?
Oh, over there.
person.
Oh, shoot.
Not at me..
oh!
Oh, uh... Okay.
Okay!
Kill!
Oh, kill!
Kill, kill, kill.
Hey.
Yeah.
Kill, kill, kill.
Kill.
Oh.
There we go.
Kill, kill, kill.
We have permission this time, guys.
We have permission to kill.
We're good.
Where is everybody?
Oh my god.
I can't.
Take out those hostiles.
Where's hostiles?
Where are they?
Oh, here.
I got them.
I got you.
I got you, buddy.
Oh.
Boss, the target's dead.
Mission failed.
Wow.
Where did that come from?
For real?
Flare.
Can I get the birds?
Oh, there's some people.
Ouchie, ouch.
What?
I got you.
Go away.
Grenade.
Oh, wait.
I have a grenade launcher.
Wait, how do I switch?
How do I switch it?
Wait, hold on.
Wait.
Uh, anyway.
Uh, what?
When did I get the...
Did I... Where?
Where?
What?
Why while aiming?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Where did the grenade come from?
Or where did the...
Where?
Oh.
No, why?
Sorry.
Please, please, please.
Don't kill him.
Don't...
All hot stuff down.
Touchdown is a no-go.
I'm going to include the helipad.
Inless escort.
Boss, cover the friendly vehicle.
I'm getting his ass.
I'm getting this guy's ass.
Come on.
It's safe.
Maybe.
Okay.
Gotta give it to the boss.
Cassette tape.
Oh.
Hey.
Oh my god.
I just broke that cactus.
I'm going to jail for real.
Oh my god.
I just broke a cactus.
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Gosh.
Where's that coming from?
Oh.
This way?
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Woo!
You're good.
Thank you.
Me?
You still talking about me?
I should have reloaded.
No.
By that!
Oh.
Dang it.
I keep pressing the wrong thing.
Semper Fi!
Holy cow!
Woo!
Semper Fi!
Oh my god.
This?
Ah!
Reload!
Oh my god.
Yeah, I know.
That's what you told me to do.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Man!
Where is he?
Oh.
My guy!
He's still alive.
It's fine.
Where the hell?
Can I hit that thing over there?
No?
Oh my god.
How are you still alive?
Where's the other people?
Enemy reinforcement.
Ah!
Shoot the kill!
Shoot.
Oh, dang it.
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
More reinforcement!
Let them get close.
Where are you scope to target enemies from a distance?
Where are they?
Oh, okay.
Oh.
What?
Woo!
Let's do it!
That was close.
It was so close.
Wait.
Not that.
Um...
Please, please let me shoot it.
Okay.
Hey!
These guys can really, uh... Can I get off the thing now?
Oh wait, I didn't reload!
I'm such an idiot!
Uh-oh, I have like seven bullets.
Hello!
Um, wait...
Let's switch to that, and uh...
Oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh!
Uh, yeah, we're good.
Just take it out, just take it out.
Take it out, take it out!
More of them!
Oh my god!
Kazuhiro Miller, I do not want to hear it from you.
I do not want to... Where are they?
I do not want to hear it from you.
Shut up taking them out when you're on the team.
Shut your face!
Please!
Here
we go.
Oh, wait.
Where did they go?
We're fine though, right?
He's where?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Hello?
Come here!
Come here, mister!
Come on!
Don't die on me!
Don't die on me, very important!
We got this!
We got this.
Damn it, I don't got this.
I missed.
Stealth mission.
This isn't a stealth mission.
Oh my god!
He'll regret it.
Oh yeah!
Look at you, you're wobbling.
Nice shot, thank you.
Why'd you crash into that, you dummy?
You stupid helicopter!
Why'd you do that?
Why did you do that?
Who's shooting at me anyway?
Thanks!
That was smooth, boss!
I know it was.
Someone's shooting at us.
Oh, that guy maybe over there?
Blow up everything and everyone!
Blow up
everything and everyone!
What?
The one guy left in the whole base is shooting.
Who could our very important...
We're leaving hot zone!
Returning to base!
Who could our very important operative be?
Confirmed!
The target is safe!
Oh!
Snake!
No way!
Is that...
Oh my god!
What took you so long?
I only got 25 kills, you guys.
Dang!
I think if I hadn't killed anybody, I would have S that.
Yippee!
We saved Hideo Kojima!
Yeah, I got an A on that.
Not bad.
What took you so long?
I think if you...
I think if you S it...
That's when he says snake.
That was perfect.
And that's when you S it, yeah.
Yay!
How are you supposed to do the tanks with no kills though?
Seems scary.
Look for the credits.
That one's a silly one that I wanted to do.
We have...
Like I said, I've never done the...
Duh.
Deja vu.
Bye, there he goes!
Thank you for that, Kazuma!
Every stream, I feel my checking account.
My savings account.
Even my PayPal account.
The money I've lost.
The time I've lost.
Mito's so cute.
You're a wisp too, aren't you?
We don't have that part yet.
We don't have...
Oh look!
And there he is!
You guys see him behind the missions?
Watch, watch, watch what he does.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you, Awesome, for the 20 gift!
Thank you!
Mr. Kojima, stop it!
Look at his little mischievous face.
I've heard that deja vu is kind of difficult though.
Is that true?
Maybe we should do this one first.
And then deja vu last.
The snatcher one.
It's kind of fun though.
No, it's not really?
Not at all?
Oh!
Oh, it's really tough to S rank.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
Okay, okay.
It's got puzzle elements.
I do know that!
I do know that.
So, we'll do these two.
We'll listen to Paz's tapes, and then, yeah.
I don't know which one I want to end on, to be honest.
Oh my gosh.
I feel like this one's more iconic.
You know?
A snake...
A snake.
S rank needs rushing, which is hard.
Ah, I see, I see.
Stop!
Kojima, stop it!
I'm trying to...
Yeah, let's end on deja vu then.
So, we'll do...
How do you say this?
Jamais vu?
I don't know France.
Even though my last name is French.
Uh...
Yeah.
What is this?
Our galaxy consists of some 300 billion stars.
Around half are orbited by planets.
Schrodinger's cat.
I've never played these last two missions before, so I'm excited.
Feeling like things should be familiar, but they are.
We got an urgent request to investigate unusual activity of the U.S.
Naval Facility.
In Cuba.
According to our men in the CIA, they lost all contact with the base shortly after a Soviet commuter jet crashed into the coast nearby.
But the strange thing is that when comms were restored 24 hours later, the only message received was conditions normal.
Oh.
And that was it.
Mmm.
The planes hit the bottom of the ocean now.
But before it sank, someone...
Some thing...
Some thing!
Murphy, I see your super chat.
I'm waiting until the cuts themselves out.
The Pentagon's assessment chimes with the intel from our on-site informant.
Signs indicate that the base has been taken over by some unknown entity.
Wow!
Intelligent beings that attack people and steal their identity.
No!
That's right, boss.
Body snatchers.
Body snatchers!
What are you calling me?
The watermelons!
Zero
or not, these things aren't exactly your jurisdiction.
But we've got a secret weapon.
A man from another world.
A dark, distant future.
Melons.
A man made into a war machine with no human body for those bastards to snatch.
Yeah!
As payment, all we need to do is hand over the XOF badges you've gathered on your missions.
Biddy biddy biddy biddy biddy b.
Yeah, so basically in the main mission, there's those little XOF patches that are scattered around the base and you just kind of find them.
Oh my god!
Original soundtrack!
But why the melons?
Because...
It's like a...
Popular thing that...
Raiden...
Like to cut up the melons in Rising.
So we're good to kill!
We're good to kill, baby.
Look at him!
He's like, go get him, kid!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Eliminate any and all snatchers occupying the Cuban naval base and prison camp.
There's no telling what will happen to the world if you lose.
Wow!
It's so weird hearing cars say run!
Yay!
Wow, that's a great shot.
Um, Murphy asked earlier if I was planning on playing, um...
VR missions.
To pick them out, you'll first need to mark a target.
That'll let you feel them out.
And, um...
Oh my god.
Cos, please show up.
I've sent the target's predicted field of movement to your eye droid.
Wipe out the snatchers posing as marines and neutralize all survivors.
Destroying them won't add to your kill count.
Oh, nice.
Eliminate the snatchers.
Um, but yeah, it's funny that you asked that, Murphy.
Because literally someone today in the meet and greet was just like, Are you gonna play VR missions?
So maybe sometime.
Oh my goodness.
Robots built using cutting edge bionics.
We have no idea where they came from or what they want.
I don't know where any of these guys are.
Like us.
But the reality is something...
Oh.
Nevermind.
Someone's there.
Try marking him.
Wait, someone...
Is he human?
Or one of them?
Where?
Feel him out.
Who are you talking about?
Who do you see?
Kazuhiro Miller has special eyes.
Who are you talking about?
There's nobody here.
There.
Huh?
He like even stopped talking.
Kazuhiro Miller...
Who are you talking about?
Kaz needs his pills.
So this guy is normal.
He's not a snatcher.
Yeah.
But still, there's something not quite right about him.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, yeah.
Because he's like...
Interrogate him.
Find out what he knows.
Oh, okay.
That's kind of fun.
Making sure there's nobody else around.
Like I said, I've never done this mission before.
So I don't know where...
A lot of the enemies are.
In this one.
Are you...
Normal?
Speak.
I can tell you where our men are stationed from.
I have no idea what's happening.
I had no idea Raiden was in ground zero.
Hello.
Well, now you do.
Turn the light off.
Thank you.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
There we go.
Thank you.
One out of 12.
Oh, see?
There's a sn... Is that a snatcher?
Wait.
I think he's... You only marked one guy.
What do you mean our guys are marked here?
You only marked one of them.
What do you mean our guys are...
I'm blinding him?
He's like, get that light out of my face!
I hear someone, like, snoring.
I think it's the guy just knocked out, though.
Get that light out of my face!
Okay.
So, because he's an alien...
We're good to kill.
What is he looking at?
What are you suspicious of, huh?
Maybe I can kill him from here.
What are those things?
Whoa!
Whoa, he's burning!
Nice, nice.
Take care of the next one.
So...
Where?
There's only 12 guys on the base?
Holy cow!
We're so fast!
Whoa!
Raiden.
Damn.
I don't know what I expected.
Let's check from up here.
Maybe there's any...
Guys we could see?
Oh, no.
Raiden, stop.
Raiden.
If there's only 12 people here...
It's more like hide and seek...
Than anything else.
Oh, oh.
This guy seems normal.
Oh!
What is that?
No mistake.
That's a snatcher.
Eliminate it.
The music?
Too awesome.
Oh my gosh.
It's too good.
Let's see.
Anywhere else?
Needle gear salad.
My beloved series.
Yeah.
Me too.
Go.
Try the intel button.
That's the base's admin building.
Security looks tight.
Does it?
I don't know.
There's nobody here.
I don't know about that, guys.
It actually looks quite dead around here.
I'm kind of scared because it's so dead.
I'm afraid to walk.
Like, I don't know.
I don't know where it's fine to walk to.
Security looks tight.
Don't lie to me.
Wait.
Is there somebody up there?
No.
There's nobody here.
Check the map.
Oh.
What's this?
Is that a landing?
What is that?
Anticipated enemy location.
Okay.
There's gonna be...
Let's go around.
I'm running around like I own the base.
I wonder if I can get that guy from here.
You know?
Also...
Well, if it isn't Saucy Jack.
Smoke grenade!
Yeah?
Thanks!
We're gonna neutralize all human survivors.
Okay.
Can I get...
What if I...
Do the...
The best...
Headshot ever here.
Oh?
Oh, shoot.
No, you're...
You're a snatcher!
I can't...
I think I messed up.
Okay, I think he's dead.
No.
What the...
Man down!
Maybe I shouldn't have done that.
Yeah, why are the snatchers able to...
Oh, see?
That's a snatcher.
Nice
work.
Take care of the next one.
Die, snatcher scum!
It's kinda cool.
Hmm...
Anybody over there?
Who are you?
A human!
Nobody will see me there, right?
Or...
Anybody else around?
This...
It's...
This base is so dead!
It's crazy!
A human...
I don't see anybody else.
Anybody else?
Trying to use my eyes...
Like a quick glance.
See literally nothing.
I'm a snatcher!
What?
Whoa!
I possess!
But I do not sn...
Snatch!
Oh!
Um...
How do we do this?
Uh...
Is there anybody over there?
How do we...
Wait.
How do I...
Ouch.
Oh.
How kind of...
You!
No!
What?
Stop!
Stop right in front of me!
Please!
Oh.
Oh, I...
Oh!
I got the other guy!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
He wakes up immediately.
That's crazy.
That gun will be as loud as any other now.
Uh-oh.
If you have to shoot...
Be careful.
Oh.
You did not hear gunfire.
You didn't.
Um...
Oops.
Uh...
It's no good.
Those snatchers just shrug off knockouts and tranquilizers.
It's fine.
He's dead.
I kicked him to death.
Maybe we can get another...
Uh...
What's it called in here?
Ugh.
What's the word?
Ooh!
I could get a rocket launcher.
No.
I was gonna say another suppressor.
Sad.
Okay.
Where's our other friends at?
Anticipated enemy location.
It's literally where I'm at.
Nobody's here.
There's no party.
Oh.
Who said that?
Oh, you.
Oh.
No.
You're a bad guy.
Oh, shoot.
Did I kill him?
No.
Oh, god.
Ooh.
This is not good.
Killed him.
Do you have to say pause in this mission?
Nope.
Standing down?
Okay.
No, in this we just have to kill the guys.
I think now the rest are inside here probably.
go.
The end of the day.
Hello.
Excuse me.
CP, this is Zulu2.
We've got unidentified gunfire.
Occasion unknown.
My bad.
CP, understood.
All take threats immediately and eliminate the distresses.
Out.
Eliminate?
No.
Alert status...
But there's like five guys.
Oh.
Wait, I need to... Okay.
And who sees me?
Oh, the camera!
Ah!
Contact!
Uh-oh.
Wait, I need to know what you are.
You're a bad guy!
Kill, kill, kill!
I think I saw another guy.
How many were left?
Not the surveillance camp.
Get out of here.
Who said that?
Nice shot, thank you!
You stinkin'... Contact!
Where?
Those guys are there?
How did I unlock the third door?
What did I do?
Oh!
What are you?
Wait, what are you?
You're so dead.
Oh, this is our last guy!
What are you?
Bad!
Any last words?
Good work, Raiden.
All snatchers confirmed eliminated and survivors neutralized.
The analysis can wait.
We need to get you out of there.
Okay.
I'm sending a chopper to the floor.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there are doors right here?
Helipad!
Oh, come on.
Raiden doesn't know how to open doors.
I'm a robot!
Cold blood?
He's literally the submission!
I'm Raiden.
Look how small his steps are.
You're so dainty, Raiden.
Can I take this guy with me?
Just for funsies?
Oh, my bad.
Wait, uh...
I'm taking him with me?
I got a new pet?
Wait, what's happening?
Reinforcements!
Where they come from?
I'll have the chopper wait in the air.
Oh, come on.
Who is it?
Oh, uh...
Who else wants to mess with me?
Oh, right there?
I don't know what you are, but...
I couldn't care.
Oh, see?
I knew.
The tower?
Oh, yeah.
Thank you.
What are you?
Oh, my god!
Deal with him first.
Hey, you!
Chill out!
I'm trying.
Oh, uh...
I got him.
I... Oh, no.
Our thing is smoking.
We're fine.
Normal patrol.
Wait, there's more?
There's more?
Where?
Let's chopper searchlight.
Oh.
There's more!
Oh, shoot.
How did I miss?
I think all these guys are baddies.
No?
We're out!
Whoo!
Oh, over here?
Oh, you!
Oh, my god.
I think I got this!
Oh, come on.
No!
Oh, my god!
Oh, my god.
That's so stupid!
I just... Ow!
Ow!
I just needed to reload!
No!
Oh, my god.
Morpho!
Okay.
So these guys first?
Oh, you!
Just kill.
Just unload.
I think he's dead.
Dead.
Just unload.
Another?
Where?
Just unload.
Oh!
I think that guy just glitched a little.
Weep.
There we go.
The chopper!
What do you mean?
I'm working on it!
Where?
Where are they
actually?
What are you talking about?
Oh, wait.
There's an actual chopper?
Where are our chopper?
Oh, you want us up there?
He's targeting the chopper.
Oh!
That's not us!
We're both reloading.
Oh my god, there's so many guys here.
There's suddenly so many guys.
Oh my gosh.
Run!
Oh!
Oh no, I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die!
Don't think anymore!
Oh my god, this part's so stupid!
Oh my god!
There's so many men!
Where did they all come from?
Oh my god!
Do I have to start at the very beginning?
Okay.
What?
This guy.
Okay, this chopper.
This is not our chopper.
This is the enemy chopper.
Nice.
You know what?
I'm just gonna...
As quickly as he came, he turned around.
As soon as he came down.
Okay.
That's the easier way to handle it, I suppose.
What are you looking at?
Hey, Aegon, where?
Did I do it?
Are there any more?
Oh, there's a guy.
Resuming normal patrol.
Never mind.
Oh my god, even more!
More?
How many more?
I'm trying!
I'm seriously trying!
Oh my god.
Ugh.
I
don't know if I actually did it.
Are you still working?
Are you still alive?
Are you dead?
Oh, you're still alive, I think.
Uh oh, we're almost out of rockets, you guys.
Get to the chopper!
Yippee!
Victory lap!
That's my boy.
Why did Kai say that?
I don't know.
Why did he say that?
Yeah!
Into the sky!
Kill the aliens!
Mission complete.
I guess it all worked out in the end.
Yeah.
Oof.
That's fine.
Snake didn't...
Keeper Sutherland didn't say anything!
He didn't say a dang word!
Why was he accredited in this?
He didn't have a single line!
All right.
The crisis is over.
Thanks to Raiden.
But they never could determine what those snatchers really were.
I just hope they didn't have anything bigger planned.
This whole thing was like some bad dream.
What a uh...
Like it seems...
It seems like they're trying to set up for something.
I can't tell if they're like actually trying to set up for Snatcher or like...
If they had other...
You know, other...
Things that they were thinking about doing with it.
Did you see that one trial?
It's called Fastest Marking of Crows.
The white armor outfit has been unlocked.
Whoa!
Hard difficulty.
I think it was mostly a reference.
Maybe.
Emotional support Kiefer.
Yeah.
Cool!
Cool, cool.
Let's do...
No?
Just this one.
Deja vu!
Peak mission incoming.
Or maybe we listen to pause tapes first.
I know I keep switching around what I want to do.
I'm just indecisive.
Spy log.
This is...
This is the one that is...
That you can listen to in Peace Walker, no?
As of today, I will be living here at Mother Base.
Now my real trial begins.
Yeah.
The doorknob was paying my room, board, and tuition.
But he has since been captured.
Womp womp.
I told the man that with no more money from the KGB, I could no longer afford school.
He bought my story.
And when I said I would be willing to work, he took pity on me and let me stay.
For some reason, Miller really pled my case.
That was helpful.
But the man is still a fool.
This is the doorknob.
His men are no better.
They think their training makes them strong.
Yeah, we listened to this one in Peace Walker.
But that kind of strength is nothing in the face of true power.
And better yet, they wait on me hand and foot, believing I am just a school girl.
That's so cute.
Looks like I won't be working too hard after all.
They love you, Paz!
Just today, while scouting out the living quarters, I saw a group of them in the corner of the deck making a fuss.
Going over for a look, I saw they were feeding a kitten.
A bunch of grown, hard men.
And they are the ones acting like school girls.
I know, because they're so cute!
Look, isn't he cute?
And then they all died!
I spoke with them.
All of them!
Disgusted, I just nodded and smiled.
I must stay in character after all.
I indulged their chit chat for a few moments.
Then one of them asked me to give the thing a name.
They had just taken it from its mother.
I named it Nuke.
I improvised some nonsense about how our compassion for living things can help prevent wars.
The men gave me a little fish.
I held it out in my palm and the kitten happily ate it up.
What a pathetic, feeble creature.
It sickens me.
It's just a cat, pause.
Stop being dramatic.
Today, Chiko invited me to go fishing with the soldiers.
Okay, these ones are all new.
I suppose finding one's own food does have its merit.
But I prefer not to be involved in such a degrading task.
Or it's just fishing.
And they're prattling on about fishing.
What's wrong with fishing?
Is it degrading?
That is nonsense.
I'm not here to find playmates.
Nevertheless, distasteful as it was, I went along in order to maintain my cover.
She is so edgy.
Chiko thrust a fishing pole into my hands.
And we went up onto the deck where several soldiers had gathered.
They welcomed us warmly.
Is this Tara Strong?
With so few women aboard Mother Base, I'm treated like a princess.
I know.
No one suspects I am neither a teenager nor a student.
They just love you, pause.
It was nice and sunny, with a gentle breeze and waves.
As I cast my line and waited for a bite, the soldiers began to ask me all sorts of questions.
As always, I answered according to our predefined scenario, feigning a smile.
As I sat there feeding them lies, the fish began to bite.
And the soldiers began to focus on their prey.
Chiko had his bait stolen by a fish and got so angry that he stood up and nearly fell into the sea.
Everybody laughed.
It almost made me want to join in too.
At some point, I got a bite myself.
The instant after I felt that first gentle tug, the fish yanked the line with astonishing strength.
Chat with me.
And I let out a cry of surprise.
I thought he was going to be huge.
It was my first time fishing.
And I was a bit flustered.
I love how it only takes the second diary entry for her, like, cave.
She starts to crack in the second entry.
I know how to turn the handle as fast as I could.
I wondered what kind of fish lived below the surface.
And thought back to the deep sea dives I had to do as part of training.
She ain't building this.
Those were difficult days.
But I remember finding the multicolored fish gliding through the water incredibly soothing.
After a hard fight, I pulled it out.
She's like, I have this hypnotherapy.
It wasn't even half a vara.
I hate men.
See Solid Snake one time.
I love men.
But I wasn't doing it for fun.
So I wasn't the least bit disappointed.
Nuke was hovering nearby with an expectant look on his face.
So I gave the fish to him.
Nuke!
All in all, a thoroughly wasted day.
Nuke on the base.
Preparations are coming along nicely.
No one suspects me of being the one to let Zdarnoff out of his cell.
You!
It is a simple home-cooked dish consisting of black frijoles mixed with arroz.
It is well known throughout Central America, not just in Costa Rica.
So it is no surprise that a Mika like Amanda would be good at making it.
But I was raised in the States from a very young age and can hardly even remember my mother's gayo pinto.
Gayo pinto.
Having to make chit-chat with that clueless bird lover in the so-called revolutionary was excruciating.
And, clueless or not, I wanted to be especially careful around Cecile, the one who actually regarded that tape.
She's got that women's intuition.
Thankfully, Miller and his men seem to believe I mistook the tape I found for one my friend made.
In any case, one can never be too careful.
Anyway, the three of us minced garlic and herbs, then cooked them in a pot with frijoles sweet-soaked overnight.
While waiting for them to cook, we sauteed onions and arroz in a frying pan.
Cecile worked the frying pan according to Amanda's directions, And then you remember at the end of Peace Walker passed as he remembered, or he knew everything about pies.
We added water to the pan and watched the arroz begin to steam.
And so it just makes it even more like...
While we waited, Amanda shared memories of her mother with us.
They had been separated because of samosa, but the taste of her mother's cooking was still fresh in her mind.
When the frijoles were ready, we drained the water, stir-frying them with the rest of the vegetables.
Quite a complicated process for home cooking.
Nonetheless, it kept them occupied.
He was playing there?
Kaz is extremely manipulative.
That guy is kind of crazy.
The only thing he has going for him is that he's charismatic.
Like, Kaz is actually insane.
I mean, the guy is really fucking crazy.
We folded it into the frijoles and added salsa, stirring the mixture as it simmered.
At this point, for some reason, the conversation turned to romance.
Why does it have to be that way whenever women get together and chat?
Cecile fancies herself to be well-versed in such matters and gave Amanda all sorts of advice.
It was harmless enough until, to my irritation, she began pestering me whether there was anybody I liked.
Not right now, I said, trying to dodge the question.
But she pressed on.
It's Snake, isn't it?
I gritted my teeth and played it coy.
Maybe.
Cecile nodded and jiggled.
He is pretty sexy, isn't he?
What a ditz.
It's all I can manage to just survive.
The thought of romance has never once crossed my mind.
I have no interest in that kind of man.
Soon enough, a rich aroma began to fill the room.
The guy has been torn already.
Yeah!
Nu came over and rubbed up against our legs, looking for a handout.
Unfortunately, it was not the kind of food a cat would like.
Sure, Jan.
We let a few of the soldiers have a bite, and then headed off to the mess hall.
The home-cooked flavor we achieved was a big hit with the men of MSF.
Yay!
Not that we are trying to arrest them or anything.
Even I could manage a dish like that.
Snake enjoyed it too.
Let me make this absolutely clear.
I have no interest in that man.
We'll keep playing, I just wanted to pause a little bit.
I have, let me make it clear.
I have no interest in that man.
Is pause sure she's not a teenager?
The edginess says other one.
She's so like, she tries so hard to be, to be so bad.
But one thing I wanted to say was, um, loving Metal Gear is accepting that literally everyone in this series is, is dog shit.
Everybody sucks, except Sunny.
But, loving Metal Gear is realizing that everyone is kind of awful, and just accepting that.
So, you know, when it's just like, yeah, Kaz is an actual psycho.
I, of course, I mean it lovingly.
Of course, I mean it lovingly.
Otacon too?
Otacon is not innocent.
He, he literally created Rex.
Sure, he's not as much of a crazy as everybody else.
But like...
Anyway, this is Raiden's slander.
Raiden's tummy is too full of gunpowder for him to be wrong.
Football, or soccer as it is known in the states, is extremely popular here.
It has not caught on yet in the U.S., but it has legions of rabbit fans all across Latin America.
These fans can get so rowdy that it is commonly believed El Salvador and Honduras went to war in 1969 over scoffles in a soccer match.
In reality, tensions between the two countries were already high.
The match was merely one of the sparks that set them off.
But these people are so passionate about this sport that the story seems plausible.
Predictably, many of the soldiers here are fans.
They have apparently divided themselves into the Costa Rican and Nicaraguan teams and started playing each other.
I love to hate Huey.
To play, you need a ball and two goals.
Is she explaining soccer?
I had absolutely no interest, but Chico insisted that I come and watch.
It was not a proper match by any means.
The pitch was not even regulation size.
But the players and spectators alike got pretty excited.
They banged empty cans and shouted cheers through the handmade megaphones.
I love these guys.
It almost felt like carnival.
Huey, the referee, blew a whistle to start the match.
The soldiers' training has left them in excellent physical shape.
But they lacked the honed skills of professionals and their play was quite rough.
Midway through, one of the men collided with another.
They started shouting at one another, but Huey stepped in.
Aw, Huey rolled in.
We have forsaken our countries.
Become one with the earth, he said, quoting Snake.
We are not competing for national pride here, and we are not fighting for the good of any one country.
This is not a war.
Soccer is a peaceful sport, am I right?
The soldiers nodded.
They know the pain of war, and they share Snake's vision.
Perhaps that is why all this resonates with them.
Nah, who each did nothing wrong?
And somehow, I was picked to fill in.
Costa Rica had the advantage up until that point.
I suppose Huey wanted to keep it balanced.
These soldiers agreed with Huey's call.
Maybe the Costa Rican players felt an even match-up would be more fun, too.
I could not be bothered to run at first.
But chasing the ball out there in the hot sun, I was soon drenched in sweat.
Before long, I found myself actively seeking out the ball, partially out of desperation.
I picked up a loose ball deep on the opponent's side of the field.
Even though he's Nicaraguan, Chico cheered me on, yelling, What do you mean, picked it up?
Come for it, shoot!
With your hands?
I launched the ball, as hard as I could, only to have it blocked by the keeper.
This appointment only increased my determination.
In the end, I didn't score a single goal, and Costa Rica gave up its lead.
It was really close, though.
We congratulated each other on a good match, and sprawled out in the shade on the deck.
She's sending me to zero, because if she's explaining soccer to a British guy...
...and sprawled out in the shade on the deck, exhausted.
The ocean breeze felt so nice on my son's soft body.
Nuke came over, it is one of his favorite spots, and stretched out next to me.
Huey refereeing a game where people are constantly using their legs is some funny irony.
...drift lazily across the clear blue sky.
It was lovely out today, so I decided to sun myself in a lounge chair up on the deck...
Wait, is this the one with strange love?
...when strange love came up to me.
Despite the need, she was in her usual long sleeves and pants.
I waved at her.
She looked away and mumbled, H-hello there.
Fancy meeting you here.
I asked if she needed anything.
Feeling her eyes creeping up and down my body like she was savoring it.
Finally, she swallowed and said, You have such beautiful skin.
Bewildered, I shook my head and said, No, not at all.
I had heard rumors that she was a lesbian.
Oh, she couldn't be after me, could she?
She continued to stare and said, No.
So she doesn't see Huey as a man.
But you must not let yourself get so tanned.
That's true.
And then she took my hand in her eyes.
That's true, that's true.
What is wrong with a little son, I asked, trying to cut the conversation short.
The L word.
But she shook her head violently.
No, you mustn't.
A young lady should take better care of her skin.
She was acting strangely now.
Say Gex.
As if aroused.
Say Gex right now.
She lectured me on the perils of tanning, how it ages skin, causing wrinkles and spots, and in the worst cases, even...
She's so ahead of her time.
I knew already that...
Gex!
...but I thought only pale-skinned Anglo-Saxons had to deal with that.
Having a scientist tell me it causes aging, though, that spooked me a little.
Wear your sunscreen, everybody!
If I have to keep playing the teenager, I will have to start paying more attention to my skin.
Sensing my anxiety, she took a small tube from her pocket.
She said it was the sunscreen she always used.
She told me to keep it.
I didn't know what to say.
I mean, you could help me.
I can't reach my back!
I was more than happy to take it, but...
A Doctor Strange, love!
Exactly what were her intentions?
Could you please?
Was she merely being nice?
Or is she really into me?
Pies!
Either way, there was no reason to refuse, I suppose.
I have undergone training.
An out-of-shape woman does not pose any real threat to me.
My god, he's so rude!
Having power means not being afraid.
It is the same on a global scale.
A country we think...
Out-of-shape woman.
...can dictate terms to a country without them.
She has a great party.
I thanked her and took the tube.
Then she offered to put some on for me.
She squirted some lotion onto her fingers and began robbing it into my chest.
Into the chest?!
It happened so suddenly, and I was so taken aback that I did not even think to protest.
She caressed my stomach with her long white fingers, then slid them upwards between my bikini-clad breasts.
What?
Wait, I spotted as her moist eyes...
It's like she's reading fanfiction.
She was beautiful.
Somehow, I found myself captivated by this woman more than 10 years my elder.
Hold still.
She whispered in my ear.
My god.
I nodded silently, unable to refuse.
My body went limp, motionless, as if in a trance.
Gently, carefully, she rubbed the lotion all over my entire body.
Or she gets the hose again.
I shouldn't have enjoyed it, and yet, I could not help myself.
For a moment, I was spellbound.
That woman is dangerous.
I had better watch myself.
Let's just take a moment to...
You could...
I'm listening to one of her spicy audio books on stream.
No, no!
What I listen to...
That is...
That is like a hundred times more sensual than anything that I listen to.
A moment of appreciation.
Um...
Golly.
Fifty shades of eyes.
I cannot think of my cat, though.
Oh, wow.
Just wow.
It's not even like the...
Like, the pride flag question mark.
It's just...
Pride flag, exclamation, exclamation, exclamation.
This is the tape your mom walks in on you listening to.
When you're playing this game...
You could tell.
She's like...
When she's like talking...
When she's like recounting the story in the...
In the tape, she's like...
She's...
She's imagining...
She's remembering everything.
Not safe for when.
I'm just...
Games are great, but streams...
Your streams always raise it to another level.
Thank you, Dwarco.
Thank you so much...
For the...
Thank you.
Yeah, she's remembering it.
Wait a minute.
She sent this to Zero, right?
I don't think so.
I think these are just...
Since they're diary entries...
I think they're just for her.
She really wanted to remember that moment.
Imagine another timeline where MGS focused on Yuri instead of Yaoi.
This is like the little Yuri crumb we get.
But actually, it's like...
That was...
That was probably...
That was like...
I mean, you know...
Everything else in Metal Gear...
You know...
If you...
You...
It's not so overt...
Where it's like...
100% confirmed...
You know?
I mean...
You know what I mean.
But this...
This is explicit.
This is like...
There's no denying.
This happened.
This...
You can't deny...
You can't...
You literally can't deny this.
But also...
What makes me laugh so much about it more is just like...
Strangelove is so...
She's so gay.
And yet...
I don't think she sees...
Huey as a man at all.
Which is just also hilarious.
Oh yeah, that's true.
There is Vulcan.
That is true.
That's probably the most overt we get...
On the yaoi end, huh?
Yeah...
That's true.
Heheheheh...
Protecting one's health is an important part of any agent's job.
But despite my best efforts...
I have caught a cold.
Awww...
Now that I think about it...
Mother Base's numbers are on the rise.
With soldiers coming from all different places and backgrounds.
Oh yeah, Vamp is canonically bi.
You're right, you're right.
Someone would bring in a virus.
You guys are right.
That said, what I have got is just a common cold.
The medical team said I'd need a few days rest.
So I've been restricted to my room and put on bed rest.
I thought I'd gotten used to not having anyone around to relate to.
I won't count the president with Ryden though.
Because he thought Ryden was a pretty lady.
Heheheheh...
Trying to take my mind off how bad I felt.
Nuke just sat there, not making a sound.
But I did have visitors.
Amanda and Chico, Huey, Cecile, Biller, and a few of the soldiers I've become relatively close to.
Amanda made me a soup with herbs.
She said we're good for a cold.
Everybody's coming to visit you!
Everybody loves you, Paz!
I will sing you a lullaby, he said.
Then broke out a guitar and sang some incomprehensible song in Japanese.
I did not need to understand the lyrics to know he is an awful singer.
Then he said, you know what is good for a cold?
Suppositories!
Here, I'll show you.
He began to take off his pants, so I blew my tissue box at him to make him go away.
Then, Strangelop showed up, saying she had some miracle Indian cure.
It has got eucalyptus eggs stuck, she said.
It works best if you rub it into your chest.
And then, she tried to take off my...
Oh my god!
Everyone is harassing this poor sick girl!
And then, I got rid of her.
Chico brought me a little flower and a cup.
That's one thing or next!
He had been growing in a little bit of earth that probably found its way on board stuck to something else.
Hello, HR?
I found this on the deck.
Here, you can have it.
Mother base needs HR.
He tried to act nonchalant, but I'm pretty sure you've got a crush on me.
Cute.
None of them understand.
If they thought these little visits would cheer me up, they were wrong.
Oh my god.
Guys, please.
Tonight, Snake himself came to my room.
Like the rest, he believes I am just a school girl and treats me as such.
Why did you abandon your country?
I asked him.
Why create the MSF?
Of course, I knew the answers already, but I wanted to hear it from him.
As I had imagined, he was not exactly forthcoming.
All he would say is that his country abandoned him, because all he could do was fight.
And that is why he needed the MSF, because that is all he is any good for.
Oh no!
Then he said, fighting is the only thing I understand, but that does not mean I have got a grudge against those who believe in peace.
I am not one of them, and I do not believe in peace.
I do not believe in peace.
Conflict is in man's nature.
We fight our enemies in order to survive.
Maybe we are not so different after all, he and I.
But that is exactly why I'm going to have to kill him, or else he will have to kill me.
When I stop and think about this wretched existence, being killed by a man like that, suddenly does not seem like such a bad thing.
We have, uh, just four more, right?
Yeah.
So seven, eight, nine, ten.
Just four more entries.
Every month, Mother Base throws a party for all the soldiers whose birthdays fall in that month.
There is something strange about a military organization having parties.
Really though, it is just an excuse to drink and make noise.
It is not easy to get alcohol in a fortress in the middle of the ocean.
Most days they are training from dawn till dusk.
They do not have time for things like drinking.
That is why Snake and Miller came up with the idea, to give everyone a chance to let loose.
Obviously, a bunch of boars like that are not going to bother with blowing out candles on a cake.
Rather, they sit there in a crowd of cigarette smoke, drink beer, eat meat, tell tasteless jokes, and swap crude themselves about one another's hometowns.
But it hardly ever breaks out into something serious.
They talk up a storm, but they're just having fun.
Yeah, they're little babies.
It is funny.
You have got members of FSLN rubbing shoulders with the UCLA's, people who once would have considered the other mortal enemies.
That's what's so beautiful about MSF.
I wonder if that is what makes Big Boss so popular.
In leaving their countries behind, they leave their hatred for other countries too.
Miller seemed a little protective of me.
Hope they're not being too crude, he said.
But soon enough, he too was drunk.
He yelled, come here and take a look at the real Kazuhiro Miller.
Is he going to take off his pants again?
Then dropped his pants and mooned everybody.
The other soldiers burst out laughing.
I have never seen such a crude, ridiculous party before.
And yet, all these people laughing and acting the fool.
Kazuhiro Miller is that type of drunk.
Is this what they call peace?
How's this so funny?
For some reason, I began to think about all that has happened since I came here.
Fishing with Chico, cooking with Amanda and Cecile, playing soccer, having visitors when I caught it cold.
When I stop and think about it, my time here has been the most peaceful of my life.
But that is about to end.
I cannot imagine he will be willing to negotiate.
It seems I am to fight the legendary big boss.
I do not know if I'll be able to beat him.
But if I have to choose between death and defying cypher, I will gladly choose death.
The thought of dying does not scare me.
But if I disobey my orders, the fear and despair awaiting me will be far worse than anything I can imagine.
You just don't know after this.
It was Cypher who took me in as an orphan.
Gave me food and a place to live.
His orders may have been unreasonable.
But I will never repay my debt entirely.
It seems I have no choice.
I must fight this man.
I must fight Snake.
Nooooooo!
Oh, thank you Minky Cosplayer.
I hope you had fun at the conventions today.
I did!
You should do meet and greets in Georgia, please.
Minto meet and greet at AWA would be fire.
I... well...
It's really a matter of like...
I want to talk about it because it's uh...
Probably something else other people think about too.
It's not like it's...
It's... it's not so simple...
I suppose.
It's really like a matter of...
If I'm a guest at the con...
You know, of course, I can do meet and greets that way.
So, if you have a place that you would want me to maybe try and go to...
Then, you know, you could ask your local convention to uh...
Invite your favorite VTuber.
So...
Um...
Or...
It really like, you know, with this...
It was Mosovox.
So, it's kind of if like uh...
If...
Uh...
Like some place that...
You know...
I have to be...
I was asked if I wanted to do...
The...
The one at Mosovox.
So...
Um...
You know, if...
If there's not a place that is doing meet and greets...
Then it's kind of like uh...
Oh, I can't...
You know, I...
I mean, could maybe do like an unofficial one.
But it's...
A little more difficult that way.
So...
Mmm...
But hopefully, you know, I would love to do AWA.
That's where...
That's...
That was the same con that we had the concert during.
So...
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
But um...
Yeah!
So...
Uh...
Just uh...
Giving you a little bit of insight on it.
But thank you!
Thanks for coming to see me!
Okay, number eight.
Do you know Miller?
Snake's right-hand man.
Oh, we know him.
Apparently has got at least one serious weakness.
Women.
He is an insatiable womanizer.
He does not bother me.
Most likely because he considers teenagers off limits.
Women.
But he has hit on every single one of the few female soldiers here at Mother Base.
Oh yeah.
They ought to be telling him where to stick it.
But end up falling for it so easily.
I'm telling you, it's his charisma!
He's literally got the riz.
And he's actually not that bad looking.
He's actually...
Anyway, today, that nasty habit got him in trouble.
He and Snake got into one of their rare fights.
And I was there to...
Shower.
They burst out of the showers completely naked, trading punches.
I am no child.
The sight of a naked man does not make me blush.
But this was something else.
Maybe this will teach you, Snake yelled as he slammed his fists into Miller's chest.
I heard later that apparently he had been too tiny.
Ah!
Kazuhiro Miller!
And that same fellow had gone to Snake with her troubles.
As I see it, he's her own fault for ready.
I'm sorry, hold on.
Can you imagine?
Can you imagine some girl being like, Boss, I was in a relationship.
I thought I was in an exclusive relationship with Kazuhiro Miller.
And then I find out that he's with...
Horned...
Horned Lizard!
What do I do?
And he's just like...
I'll go talk to him.
What advice does this man have?
I'll go teach him a lesson.
Like this guy!
I can't imagine.
I can't imagine a snake...
A big boss peace walker snake literally having any advice.
I guess he does kind of like talk to Chico and is like, You got a little crush on past, which is cute, but...
Like a grown woman coming up to him being like, Kazuhiro Miller is cheating on me!
I don't know.
It's like...
I was...
Okay, sorry.
I had to pause it because it's the...
The myth...
The image is too funny.
Be deceived like that.
If she is too dumb to see through Miller's lies, then she got what she deserves.
Damn.
But this was not the first time that it happened.
Or the second.
And snake read Miller the riot act.
Miller argued back.
And what began as a shouting match...
What are you arguing about?
You son of a bitch, Miller yelled as he swung.
You're in the wrong Miller!
Not bad, said snake smiling.
But not good enough.
And then he was back on the offensive.
And they're naked.
All of all this is happening.
They're setting it up.
And their bodies were covered with bruises.
Well, Arowana, the thing about love is...
Their bodies, deadly weapons.
They were each bleeding from a dozen places.
I'll speak to him in a language he understands.
Take some offense.
Even so, it was far less gruesome than if they had given it their all.
It was obvious that one of them would be dead were they fighting for me.
And also, they're showering together.
I guess that's kind of normal in these vases.
Try this then!
Snake parried, then responded in kindness.
Gotta hit one with the mouth.
But I could tell he was not aiming for anything vital.
You are one tough bastard, boss, Miller muttered.
A smile crept across his face as he caught his breath.
And then they went right on fighting.
No, we can't do a watch along of Snake and Kai's at the sauna.
I will.
He was combat without hatred or hostile intent.
I can't.
I can't do violence like this before.
And yet, it was more than just a friendly tussle.
They were utilizing every technique they knew.
It was not a sporting match.
They were not playing by the rules.
How could they keep this up?
Paz, why are you noticing they're glistening?
I know these details!
And the bizarre scene came to an end.
Paz is a little part of Purcell.
They looked at each other's battered bodies.
Paz, you hear a Miller.
And then Purcell laughing.
Embracing and congratulating each other on a good fight.
You don't seem so idiotic.
I still cannot fathom such behavior.
But somehow, I got the sense that for all his womanizing, Miller really only trusted one person.
And that was Snake.
There was no way I could ever come between the two of them.
And at that thought, I began to feel as if I had lost.
Lost what, Paz?
Lost what?
All of Mother Base is preparing for a festival.
Since Snake and his soldiers spend so much time fighting, they are setting aside one day a year for peace and relaxation.
I do not know all the details, but apparently that is what Snake and Miller decided.
These soldiers love the idea, of course.
There is so little fun to be had here that everybody looks forward to events like these.
That is so well and good.
But somehow, I got roped into getting on stage.
Come on, we even both have peace in our name, said Miller.
And Zadarna, that old Ruski's name, has something to do with peace too, right?
Hey, as long as we are having a day of peace, we ought to get an act together.
The Three-Piece Band.
I thought he was joking.
Oh, that hurts.
He then proceeded to share his idea without bothering to check with me.
And now, I am slated to sing.
Apparently, he had heard me on the deck one day, and since then, he's wanted to form a band.
Oh, what are you doing on the deck just singing, girl?
Everybody's looking forward to it.
So there is no way for me to back out now.
I have never done anything like this.
Oh, neat.
But it does feel kind of nice to know that people are looking forward to it.
I mean, it cannot be any worse than Miller's singing.
But modifications to Zeke are already finalized.
And I must complete my mission.
Betray Sai for now.
And I will face a fate far worse than death.
He's dead.
Still, there's no need to put things in motion just yet.
What difference would it make you just wait a little while longer?
No, I sing all the time.
A whole day of peace.
The mission can't wait until after that.
Can it not?
I know I'm only delaying the inevitable.
Where did it come?
I like how this version's different from...
One of us will have to die.
Snake, or me.
Of the one...
The cassette we have.
If I could just come up with some way to stall Cypher.
At least until our day of peace.
When did I start having thoughts like this?
Ehhh...
My cover is blown.
They know nothing of Cypher or my true objective.
But they know I am a spy.
There is no more time left.
I must act now.
I must complete my mission.
How did it come to this?
Wait, uh, solely.
All I wanted was three more days.
Just three.
Miller's already finished writing the song.
It is called love deterrent.
It is about a girl who cannot express her true feelings.
I have been practicing.
I am no pro, but I was pretty sure I would do a decent job.
Not a music U is a pro, actually.
Cypher found out that Zeke was complete.
He must have someone inside Mother Base besides me.
Spinning his tightly wound web of control.
Leaving no room for individual will.
Typical.
When they found out Zeke was complete, I was ordered to execute the operation immediately.
If I was going to enjoy just one day of peace, I had to ensure the plan could not move forward.
I tried to sabotage Zeke.
I thought by damaging the drive system, they would have no choice but to delay their plans.
I waited until midnight, and then snuck into the hangar.
There would be trouble if it looked like sabotage.
I selected one of the drive system's load-bearing parts, and carefully worked to warp its shape.
The legs drive system requires a high degree of precision to operate.
Even the smallest deviation would have done it.
Then, Chico walked in.
Chico...
Maybe it was one of those nights where he could not sleep.
In any case, he saw me, panicked, and took off running.
Chico...
It would have been easy to kill him.
But I could not.
I know he likes me.
He's just a little baby.
It is not as if I would ever have an interest in a child like him.
But I could not pull the trigger.
Not at him.
Not in the back.
Will he tell them?
Or is there a chance he will keep it a secret?
Protect me.
No.
He knows now.
Knows I am not who he thought I was.
He ran without even questioning what I was doing.
There is no chance he does not know.
And soon, all I have built here will end.
And if Cypher has another agent among them, If he finds out, I tried to sabotage Zeke.
This place will no longer be my heaven.
Then it is settled.
I make my move now.
Chico walked in before my sabotage was complete.
So Zeke should still be operational.
It might not run at full speed or power.
But I do not have time to fix that.
Without Zeke, I do not have a chance in hell of winning.
I must act fast before Chico sounds the alarm.
I don't think Chico...
Chico wouldn't have done that.
He wouldn't have.
I just did not think it would be so soon.
Chico would have given you a chance.
Metal Gear Zeke, activate.
The pause diaries.
I must act fast.
Right after I record this.
I was thinking that too.
And then she took her clothes off?
Yeah.
She didn't want them to...
You don't want them to get wet with the water.
It would just...
It would just make it harder to move.
It's the only reason.
All righty.
We've got one last mission to do.
Words and deeds.
By the way, Deja Vu missions encourages multiple plays.
So we'll leave it up to you on how to handle it.
We need guide info.
We're all on standby.
Thank you, Chico!
I think I might need some help.
I know where like some of like...
Some stuff is.
I know...
I know some stuff.
So...
Only if I ask for a hint will we do the hint.
Well, I want a hint.
So...
Yeah!
Deja Vu is really cool.
So...
Recreate the strangely familiar scenes shown in the mysterious photographs.
And head for the gold.
Let's try it.
There's a lot of easter eggs beyond the objectives.
Oh, is there?
I think actually I've only watched someone play this mission like...
Like very few times.
Like once or twice or something.
A long, long time ago before being like...
No, I want to...
So I don't remember so much of it.
But I remember like, you know...
There's like some things that I'm like...
Ah, you know?
But it...
But for those who know...
Don't say anything, okay?
Don't say anything yet.
The easter eggs only pop up after completing the mission once.
Ah!
I do know one thing about like the guards.
Which is kind of fun.
Yeah!
What is that?
Yay!
Look, it's even the...
It's actually even the...
The picture on the title screen of Metal Gear Solid.
Wahoo!
Kept you waiting, huh?
Ah!
Crazy.
Oh, we start here.
Boss, I've uploaded some photos to your eye droid.
Oh my god, hello?
Using those clues to find the locations they show.
And recreate the scenes they depict.
We're counting on you, snake.
Commence date.
Oh, sorry.
A chopper and two sentries.
A box and lights.
Okay, I know where that one's a helipot.
A surveillance camera with a green light.
Where could it be?
Oh, whoops, my bad.
A soldier?
And a tank?
A car.
The last photo's missing.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot it.
Okay.
Snake, it should be on the back of the disc case.
Or what about the manual?
There's gotta be a clue somewhere.
The manual?
The log?
Not the log.
Maybe...
Here?
Is it under options?
Support and legal information?
Wait, under where?
Check the manual.
Game settings, maybe.
No.
I want to keep reflex mode on.
Oh, under where?
Shut up.
Okay.
Actually, I don't know where that Moai...
Oh, my girl walks out!
Is this on Steam?
It might be a PDF manual.
Yes?
Shadow Moses Island.
A remote island off the coast of Alaska.
Or not.
Did you guys hear the wolf though?
Good morning.
Good morning, sleeping beauty.
That's just a guy chilling.
Where are the birds at?
I didn't even know you could mark animals in this game.
Let's see.
I don't know where the guys are in this.
Wait, how many?
I marked one, but did it say how many guys there were?
As usual, this is a one-man infiltration mission.
Yeah.
Weapons and equipment OSP.
Wait, actually?
This is a top secret black op.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait a second!
I don't have anything.
Oh, shit!
I just noticed!
Kazuhiro Miller!
Why didn't you say that earlier?
Weapons OSP.
You didn't check?
I don't even...
I'm just so used to starting with stuff.
I don't even think about it.
There's gotta be something in here then, right?
No!
Oh!
Goose Babble!
Wow.
Ghost Babble.
Okay, good.
There's nobody up there.
Sometimes that guy can get you good.
Give him a little...
Whoa, whoa!
That bird scared me.
Can I get in there?
Is there anything in here?
Oh, a shotgun!
You know what?
Uh...
Better than nothing, I suppose.
Better than nothing.
I don't know if there's anybody in here, actually.
Didn't check.
Doesn't seem to be the case.
I'm just looking around.
Is this...
Oh, this is like regular prisoner.
Wait, we get a cutscene for this?
We can call Miller when looking at the titles.
Oh, okay.
If you see any logos, feel free to code at guys.
I will.
Oh, no!
Fox!
Um, okay.
He's just like, that happened?
He's dead.
It looked like a heart attack.
Wait a second.
What do you mean, wait a second?
Complete your thoughts.
Where...
Is there any more guns besides the shotgun?
I...
I will...
Oh my god.
No.
Is there actually somebody in there?
Oh, gross.
No way!
No, thank you!
Wait, can we get him out of there?
The Sasaki family legacy.
Oh my god.
It sounds horrible.
It sounds...
Wait.
Oh, I can't.
Okay, nevermind.
Oh my god.
It sounds so bad.
It sounds terrible.
He's fighting for his life in there.
Truly, actually.
Let's see.
Hold on.
I like how you can hear the wolf sometimes.
Are you all right in there?
Someone's in the outhouse.
Some soldier with stomach trouble?
Yeah, no.
I think it's gonna be a while.
Better leave it alone.
No.
Oh my god.
No kidding, a man with stomach trouble.
He has to keep flushing.
Oh, I don't have any.
Oh, this is bad.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I can go around.
Maybe there's something in here.
Ouch, ouch, cactus.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
What?
Where is everything?
I'm afraid that guy's gonna turn around.
The crows are ominous, huh?
I mean, the ravens.
Where's any weapons here?
Maybe I go to the armory and I can get something.
They don't just leave stuff lying around.
They did!
They did in the other missions.
What are you talking about?
I wish I could see how many people were...
On...
Oh, there's a guy.
Okay, now we can see.
What?
I didn't get a...
I marked him, but it didn't...
It didn't say marked blank out of blank.
Aw, man.
I like kind of having an idea of how many guys are on...
Around, but...
I guess this time we're just gonna have to...
Figure it out.
Can you still hold them up with a shotgun?
I just don't...
We only have not a lot of bullets.
Mark?
The map has been updated.
Okay.
Oh, man.
Is there a car around here I can put you in?
Is there a car or anything around here I can...
I can drop you inside?
Maybe over here.
Hopefully there's no one else around.
So, you got a marking.
Oh, there is someone else.
I'm just gonna put him in the grass.
One second.
I didn't want him waking up, but...
You know what?
Oh, that's fine.
Does this guy turn around?
Right?
Oh!
We gotta go up there!
I also hear another guy walking.
Hold on.
This guy.
Yeah, I...
I heard him.
Kojima.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta use...
I know what we gotta do there.
It's kinda...
It's actually really cool.
Shoulda grabbed his gun.
Maybe you're right.
Where is it?
I think it was under the light.
Did he have one?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, but I...
I...
Oh, but it has more...
I feel like the shotgun would be better...
Because it's stronger, but...
Eh, this has more ammo.
Mm-mm.
Trying not to get noticed by this guy.
I don't wanna be noticed by that guy over there either, but I'm afraid if I try to open the door, somebody's gonna notice me and I'll...
This one's kinda tricky.
Why don't I have a drink?
This sucks.
You got anything to say?
There's some...
The map has been updated.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Good to know.
Can I put him in there?
Dang it.
Into the corner you go.
What?
Where though?
The map has been updated.
What's this?
Hand got all the way over there?
Oh, I think this is the mark that...
Oh, whoops.
That guy was telling about.
This.
Yeah, logo marking.
You can wake him up and then immediately...
Oh.
True.
I'll try it.
Uh-oh.
Freeze.
Yeah, get down.
Get down.
He's like stuck in the corner.
It's pretty good, actually.
Oh,
that sucks.
Oh, that sucks.
I forgot to tell him to get down.
Oh,
the music though.
You'll just let him bleed out.
Yeah, screw that guy.
Oh, that's a magazine.
That's nice, at least.
You can try and distract people.
I hear footsteps, but I don't know where they are.
It's scaring me.
Get out of there.
No, no.
This is actually pretty good.
I don't know where I am.
I don't know.
What the?
I'm working on it.
What do you mean fire?
Are they bugged?
Nope, they're... they're leaving.
Okay...
Oh, there's another guy there.
Nice.
Yep.
Yeah!
Kojima Productions.
Maybe now I can go into the armory.
Don't turn around.
Awesome.
Kojima Productions.
Hang grenade.
We'll take anything that we can get, I guess.
Oh, whoa.
Uh...
A sniper!
We could just take out everybody.
CP, this is Delta II.
We've checked the area and found nothing.
Calling off the search.
Over.
Nice!
This is CP.
Understood.
Keep this hard up.
Does not have a lot of ammo, but...
Um...
I don't think there's...
Sorry, I'm just looking around.
Uh...
Yeah.
Is Deja Vu PC exclusive?
I don't know, actually.
Uh...
Will they know?
Oh, come on!
So unlucky.
The unlock requirement...
I don't remember what it is for this one.
CP, this is Zulu VI.
Unidentified gunfire.
Can't tell where it's coming from.
Over.
This is CP.
Understood.
We are under attack.
All units on alert.
Oh, dang.
Maybe I can get him through the...
DELTA VI.
Nice.
We've got unidentified gunfire.
Location unknown.
Over.
Where could he be?
This is CP.
Locate threat immediately and eliminate as necessary.
Out.
Where could he be?
I still have my other gun, yeah.
They're coming in.
And I will take them out.
Come on.
I don't care.
Guy's crying over there.
Are you alright?
Which way he's coming?
Bleed.
CP.
This is Zulu II.
Identified gunfire.
Can't tell where it's coming from.
Over.
This is CP.
Understood.
Locate threat immediately and eliminate as necessary.
Out.
Okay.
I think we're good now.
Let's see.
Uh.
We gotta go...
Into the...
Oh.
What was that?
He just opened that door!
Oh.
He thought I was inside.
What an idiot.
He thought I was inside the place.
Dummy-dumb.
No.
I was underneath.
I was under the ground.
How would I be shooting them from inside?
Use your brain.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's hide somewhere.
It's really smart AI.
I'm telling you.
This game is...
Crazy.
This game is so crazy.
What?
If I look at the log, you guys said then call.
Call mayor.
If I look at the...
Wait.
Or is it...
No.
Title.
What do you mean title?
Like return to title?
Oh, and you see a title logo.
Oh!
I was like, what?
What are you...
Oh, so we should have done it for Ghost Bevel.
I know we gotta do this one.
Okay, nice.
We just hit a checkpoint.
I think as soon as I go in the middle there though, they'll...
It'll activate...
Um...
Of...
Of alert.
Oh.
Hello.
Yeah, I could go back for it.
You're so right.
Since we know where it is.
The old foxhound local.
Is there anybody else?
That's you.
Anybody else?
Nope.
Oh.
Is that it?
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait.
There it is.
Oh, I was supposed to grab it.
Oh.
Oh God.
There's a guy right there.
I don't even know where they're shooting.
Alright.
Guys.
Don't push yourself.
Fall back to a safe position.
Okay.
I'm safe.
I have to pee so bad actually.
I wonder if there's anyone over here.
CP, this is 207.
Lost visual contact.
Heading the last known position.
Over.
I saw something red there, but...
Oh my God.
I didn't think.
Holy hell.
I thought it was just a color.
Did they hear that?
Oh, there's one there too.
There's one there too.
I see it.
I don't think you can...
Sorry, Snake.
You need the heal?
I don't think you can grab them.
You don't think they heard that?
I wonder if there's anything down here.
Besides mines, obviously.
Anything else around here besides...
Besides mines?
Oopsie.
Hitting Mike Tyson's ass.
Thank you.
For the five gifted.
I'm gonna hide in the...
In here.
Sorry guys.
And I'm gonna go to the bathroom, okay?
Don't let Snake get caught, okay?
He's just...
He's one with the wall.
Alright?
I'll be right back.
No promises.
We're just gonna let the alert...
We're just gonna let it happen.
You know?
Chilling with my godfather at work.
Got this in the background.
He loves your laughs.
It's great.
Thank you.
I'm also gonna grab some more water.
I'll be right back.
Go prone at least?
Okay.
Alright.
I'll be right back.
You guys be on the lookout, okay?
Wait.
Cp, this is Zulu-2.
We've checked the area and found nothing.
Calling off the search.
Over.
This is Cp, understood.
Stay on the alert.
Out.
Cp, this is Delta-3.
We've finished our search of the area.
Zulu-7, what's wrong?
Come in, Zulu-7.
Cp, this is Delta-9.
All quiet here.
No sign of the enemy.
Standing down.
Over.
This is Cp, understood.
All fire teams, return to your posts.
Out.
I'm back.
Is everything good?
Are we okay?
Is everything alright?
I thought I saw something shiny here, but it's a plant.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
I feel like there should be something down here, no?
I guess maybe not.
It's all...
What's it called?
All clear?
They got close, but we distracted them.
Good job, team.
Zulu-7 disappeared from the face of the game.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Zulu-7.
Alert is all clear.
Let's go!
Okay, let's go get that.
Let's not...
Let's...
Get be exploded...
By...
Um...
Bombs.
This is a minefield.
One of your fans.
Something...
Oh!
See?
Hey, aren't you supposed to be able to pick these up, though?
No?
Messed up.
I saw the red light, and I seriously thought it was just like a... Like, a lighting thing.
I really thought.
And I think while I was on the toilet, I think I remember where the moai is.
What?
Oh, wait.
What's that?
Metal Gear.
Wait.
Ghost Babel Erasure?
No way.
It's messed up.
That's messed up, Kaz.
Okay, let's look at the photos again.
If you want to finish the mission, head for the goal.
I've marked it on your map.
If you want to look for those other scenes, go ahead.
Oh.
What?
What do you mean by that?
Where is this, anyway?
Oh, this is the... Intelligence?
The tower?
I think... What?
Darkness.
Like some kind of blackout.
Snake.
It should be on the back of the disc case.
Or what about the manual?
There's gotta be a clue somewhere.
Huh?
How do I create that one?
Do I, like, blow up the tank?
A surveillance camera.
Okay, that one's... With a green light.
Green light.
This area...
This area looks by the admin building.
A chumper and two sentries.
What?
I... Oh, I wasn't on the... Oh, there's gotta be two guys!
Two men.
Uh-oh, I gotta not kill all the men, huh?
A well-placed grenade.
Yeah!
Okay.
Alright.
Back at it.
I might need a hint for the blackout one, since I'm, like, not sure where to look.
Almost there.
Almost where?
To the gold?
No, no.
We... We have more things to look at, cause...
Two guys, one hindu.
Sickos.
Wonder if there's a logo in here.
Oh, there is a magazine.
Yep.
Security camera with a green light.
Oh wait, there's no security camera here now.
Fancy.
Okay, hold on.
I think the mobile is in here.
Where?
Where is it...
Snake.
This is Kazuhiro Mile.
It's been a long time.
Master.
What are you doing here?
Oh my god, that's too good!
Okay, it's not this one.
Is that it?
Is that what?
What are you talking about?
Almost there.
Stop talking, Kaz.
Is that it?
Is what it?
What are you talking about?
Almost there.
Oh, I see, I see, I see, I see.
This one.
All the cameras are in different places.
Is that it?
There it is.
Yay!
Yeah, the surveillance camera.
That's really weird hearing.
Keeper Sutherland say that.
Great, you recreated a scene.
I recreated...
I'm making it.
I'm causing a scene.
Right now.
Wait, I need another guy.
At the...
What's that?
What is that box?
I need another guy at the...
Helicopter.
Remember that time there was a camera?
So...
Memorable.
It is though.
It actually is.
It is memorable.
What is he talking about?
He's...
He's driving me crazy.
I think he wants me up there.
Also the clouds.
Holy moly.
Almost there.
I killed him?
No, I didn't.
I might have.
Guys, shut up!
Holy cow.
Please shut up.
Wait.
Uh...
Why is there gotta be...
It's not right.
There's something missing.
Ugh!
It's not right!
There's something missing!
Okay.
I guess I can't do that one.
My bad.
My bad!
Is that it?
But I can...
Complete the mission without...
Getting all of them.
I suppose.
So...
If it's...
If it's like kind of...
Messed up.
Then you know.
It is what it is!
Let's go in this one.
Maybe the moai...
Oh...
Snake...
Right here.
There you go.
I think the moai might be in here.
Turn...
It's a wall.
Turn the other way.
Uh...
Nope, that's...
Right...
Here!
No, uh...
Here...
Oh, that's a wall.
Here!
Right...
It encourages multiple plays, so you're good.
Yeah.
Right...
Here!
What?
Where is he?
Oh, wait.
Or...
Or is it downstairs?
Where?
Pause is.
Pause.
Almost there.
What...
What is this music?
What am I close to?
Um...
Hold on.
Music change.
Yeah.
Head for the gold.
A chopper and two sentries.
Okay, so we can't do that one.
Huh.
Where could it be?
I'm looking at it, but I don't...
The power!
That's right!
A soldier...
And a tank?
Uh...
We can turn off the power around here.
Yeah.
Where at, though?
I don't remember.
Is that it?
Oh my god.
Over here, over here.
Beep!
That's another scene recreated.
Nice work.
Thank you.
We're as close as go check on the power system.
Over.
CP, this is Delta IV.
We'll investigate ASAP.
Ouch.
The music is too good.
I think this is where they want me to go to end...
Oh my god.
I didn't know there was actual guys up here.
I just thought...
I thought they were automated.
Oh...
The hint on the back of the box was the Hideo...
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
Um...
Hold on now.
I don't think they're gonna look over here, so...
If they do...
A soldier...
And a...
A car.
The more eyes!
The only thing I'm like...
Where?
A chomper...
And two...
Where could it be?
Oh, shoot.
Who sees me?
This guy?
Seriously?
You don't.
Don't lie.
You...
Oh!
Metal Gear Rising!
If you wanna finish the mission, head for the goal.
If you wanna look for those other scenes, go ahead.
Stop!
You don't see me!
Metal Gear...
Something something...
Oh, shoot.
I should leave.
I'm getting out of here.
Yeah, you don't see me, dummy.
You don't see me, dummy, idiot.
Stupid.
No perceive.
Yeah.
Oh, it's completely dark in here.
Maybe the Moai...
Oh, it's somewhere around here.
I like how the guy investigated the power and then...
Just decided not to turn it back on.
Yeah, I was thinking it looks like these.
Oh, but no.
Moai...
Getting colder?
Who the hell are you?
Can I actually save you?
I think he'll die too.
Oh.
Oh no!
I beat you!
Bye-bye.
Oh.
Dead.
Again?
Woah!
What is that?
What's happening?
Ah!
What?
I've never seen that before.
Fox?
Thanks, Fox Engine.
Who saw me?
Oh.
There's a guy, like, right there, actually.
Maybe I can get him.
Come here.
Oh, nope.
He's just standing there.
Bless you.
Oh, no.
He's coughing.
Oh, I don't... I do not want what you have.
I do not want... I missed it.
What did I miss?
The... Mulai?
Mulai?
Woo!
Way of the room.
Is he so tiny?
I... I'm actually blind, you guys.
Take a left at the door.
Like, here.
Oh!
I ran right fast over!
Yes, you recreated another scene.
Yes!
Yes, you recreated another scene!
What the?
No freaking way.
Oh, my God.
No!
Wait.
Ah!
No, no, no.
No.
Oh.
Uh.
Sorry.
You too.
Asshole.
God.
Uh.
Um.
Hold on.
Where is the goal now?
It was where I thought it was.
Right?
Up... up... up... Actually, I don't know.
They didn't even try.
I don't know if I'll get that one.
A car.
We had a big car, but we didn't have a small car.
What is the car?
Oh, the car is probably in reference to...
Um...
Like the end scene.
With, when you're going again...
When you're leaving Shadow Moses.
Yeah, the ending.
The car is beside the helicopter.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
The escape scene.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, we can probably try and do that.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, clear.
Yup.
Yup, clear, yup.
So clear.
Oh my god, wait, don't see me.
There's four of them!
What if I just...
Ah, so close.
Smoke him out!
Yeah, that would have been good.
Oh, starting to get daylight.
Zulu 7 is alive!
That's our goal, Zulu 7.
I hate that guy.
Oh, I can try again.
I'll make it this time.
What
else we got in here?
Oh, is that a sniper?
Oh, shoddy!
Oh!
I'll take that.
Definitely ruining...
Oh.
CP, this is Delta 6.
We've arrived on the scene.
Checking the area.
Over.
Yeah, check the area.
CP, understood.
Keep your eyes open.
Out.
Is that guy also gonna report something over there?
What are you reporting?
There's the car.
We'll get this guy once he, uh...
Comes around.
Yeah, the spotlight.
Who said that?
Oh!
Uh...
That's awkward.
Oh no!
Spray and pray.
Oh, did I go too far?
Oh damn, I went too far.
I don't think he knows what to do.
He looks really confused.
Can I get him through the bag?
Oh!
I think we killed everybody, you guys!
Woohoo!
It's my car now!
What am I supposed to...
Almost there?
Oh, ah!
Oh!
Because it looks like the tunnel!
Oh my god, that's so funny.
Okay.
We created liquid.
I don't like that.
I don't like...
That...
Name.
Okay!
That guy's bleeding out.
I guess we did most of them, which is great.
I guess they're all dead.
My base now.
Here, hold on.
I'll fill it in.
Take another look at the VI.
The V... Oh.
Like the...
Droid?
And then...
The tank!
I didn't even see a tank.
Hmm...
You can still do the tank?
Where is it?
You can't do the helicopter because you murdered everyone.
It's fine because I couldn't do it because I had already murdered the guy anyway.
Tent area southwest.
Okay.
So...
Where I...
This way.
So like this area.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go baby!
What if there's somebody left though?
I'll be scared.
Oh, that scared me.
I thought it was a dog.
It is a dog!
I mean...
It's a fox.
Hound!
Tent area.
Ah, there it is.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Is that it?
Almost there.
What do I do here?
Just...
Explode it?
Is that it?
Almost there.
Could you bring a body there?
Oh...
Is that it?
Ah...
Throw it down the hatch.
Ah!
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Almost there.
Let's try it.
There he is!
That's so good.
Yay!
Yes!
You recreated another scene.
Yes, I did.
What was he doing inside?
Snapping?
Probably.
Actually though, isn't it like super uncomfortable inside tanks?
It's like super cramped and hot.
Okay.
I think we've done all we can do.
Very hot.
I don't!
Kaz, I can't do it!
I can't do it!
Okay.
I think it is up here.
Up there?
I have to go too?
Maybe.
Oh yeah, these guys are gone now because I killed them.
Oh, oh, this way.
I was like, oh no, wait, I'm going to get caught by the spotlight.
Everybody's dead.
It's cramped, but not as bad as you think.
Wait, can I control the spotlight?
Wait, let's sneak it up.
Now I'm playing Metal Gear.
You killed everybody.
Is this where you need me to go?
Oh my god.
Ah, that's where the pistol is.
Wait, where's the gold?
Oh, it's...
In there?
Down there?
Right there?
Can I jump from here?
Or am I going to get hurt?
Let's try it.
Oh, wow.
Snake's got sturdy knees.
What's in here?
Wait, I don't think I've ever noticed this before.
Those mice are Alaskan field mice.
Uh, no.
No, they're not.
Master.
How are you feeling?
Okay.
No way, that's the exit.
Oh!
I did it!
Oh, I did it.
I'm a genius.
Sea for sea.
You created a lot of...
Scenes!
Oh my god, Kiefer Sutherland having to say master.
Wonder how he...
Yes, sir.
Yes.
He made it to the goal.
What's that, sir?
There's those scenes left to recreate.
Yes, sir.
Yes, I...
No, sir.
Understood.
I
wanna know what happens if you...
If you complete all of them!
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Is this Kai's pretending to be awesome?
Yeah!
Oh my god, best ever.
That's so good.
But I think...
Actually, if I...
Hold on.
I'm just gonna go into it real quick.
I'm not gonna actually do it.
I do wanna see if it changed, though.
Yeah, we didn't get the quiz.
Probably because...
We didn't complete all the scenes.
Hmm...
We didn't get the quiz!
Yeah, usually...
There's like a quiz at the end that, uh...
I wanna see if it's changed at all, though.
A pseudo-historical recreation.
Hold on, I'm gonna skip it, sorry.
Oh, you can't skip it.
It's like...
No, this is peak.
You're not allowed to skip.
It's so...
It's so ISO.
At one point, there was Kaz pretending to be Liquid pretending to be Kaz.
You're right!
Kept you waiting, huh?
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Yippee!
Now I'm annoyed that I didn't get it.
I'm...
I'm disappointed in myself.
I've uploaded some photos to your iDroid.
Use them as clues to find the locations they show, and recreate the scenes they did.
I would say...
That I could, like, do this quickly, but I really don't think I can.
Even if I know where everything is...
Shadow Moses Island.
A remote island off the coast of Alaska.
Oh no, the guys aren't changed.
Um...
You can get them to change into Shadow Moses people.
You got this?
Just don't kill everybody.
Easier said than done.
Um...
As usual, this is a one-man infiltration mission.
Weapons and equipment OSP.
Maybe we can...
Maybe we can get...
Um...
The one...
Did I say...
Did I say thank you, Jesse?
Sorry, my brain is a little fuzzy right now.
Thank you so much for the farm, Captain!
Thank you!
Um...
Maybe we can try and get the helicopter first.
You know?
Was there anything in here?
Oh, there were some magazines in here.
Yeah, let's grab that at least.
So we have some...
Even though...
It didn't even...
I tried to throw the magazine before to distract...
To distract the guy, and...
He completely ignored me.
Completely ignored me.
Blah...
There's only 16 guys on the base.
No wonder it was so easy to kill everybody.
How do I get the other guy to come over, though?
Oh no, they're right there!
Okay.
Uh, so once I get this...
I can kill everybody.
Ah, there it is.
Now we can kill everybody!
Wait, I think I also need the...
Just like old times.
I think...
Just what I expect from the legendary snake.
Why is he saying it like that?
I think I also...
Oh.
Who noticed me?
That guy?
No, sir.
I think I also...
Sorry, I keep...
My...
The medicine.
Um...
I think I also need to get the...
Spotlight one.
With...
Without killing people.
Just...
Yet.
Hand grenade.
We'll take that.
Uh...
What are you?
Oh.
The shoddy.
We'll take you.
Yup.
Maybe we can get it.
You know what?
I believe.
Even if...
Even if it's not a first try then.
Haha.
Oh my god.
Please snake go inside.
There we go.
Master.
Didn't you get it when you picked up the thing first time?
Do I not have to get all of them again?
Or no?
Don't I have to get all of the...
Scenes again?
Like...
Complete.
You have to get them again.
Yeah, yeah.
Check the eye droid.
That's a good idea.
Oops.
I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty sure this is...
If you want to finish the mission, head for the goal.
I've marked it on your map.
Yeah, yeah.
A hundred percent.
A hundred percent I have to do it.
So...
Let's see.
Get the sleepy gun.
I'm working on it.
You know it's all the way up there.
Go investigate.
Thank you.
Oh, shoot.
I hate...
Oh,
I have a gun now.
That's right.
Fox, die!
Oh.
Okay.
I don't think anybody would come down here.
Don't kill everyone.
I could.
I don't have to get an S in this, do I?
If so, I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna, you know...
I don't play to get ranks, you guys.
I just play for fun.
Another prisoner.
Looks like he's alive.
Yeah, you don't have to get an S.
Yeah.
I just like to play for fun.
Just the scenes.
You can throw...
You can stun cameras by throwing a mag...
You can?
Throw a mag at them during slow-mo?
I had no idea.
Oh, that's huge.
Thank you.
I'm feeling like him right now.
Bye-bye.
Resuming normal patrol.
A man is dead and you're resuming normal patrol.
I don't think there was anybody down here.
Bye-bye.
You can stun guards in slow-mo by throwing snake's cake to them.
Nice work.
Thank you.
I like the praise.
Isn't there a guy around there?
Hello, little mouse.
Oh, there's an armory right there.
Very interesting.
Maybe that worked.
If not...
Oh, that totally worked.
Wait, I don't want him to see me though.
I don't...
Can you jump dive in this game?
Or is that only in V?
Can I get in there without him seeing me?
Is the question...
I think so.
You can?
X or square?
Really?
Okay, I'll try it.
Wait, this got a...
This got a suppressor on it.
Wait, what do you mean?
I wonder what it's used for.
Oh!
Wait.
It disappeared.
I'll tell you why, but it looks like that gun's light erased the marking.
You see any more of those things around there?
Oh!
I forgot about this.
Wait, but my shot good.
What did I do?
My shotty.
Just remember that it's in there, everybody.
Well, that guy just...
That guy just left.
Oh, dang it.
I didn't get to mark him.
No, I had no clue that he would leave though.
Looks like that's nothing special.
What do you mean?
What?
The disrespect.
The disrespect!
Wait, I only know where two are though.
You guys wanna help me with the other ones?
Yes, I did.
Don't get on.
We'll investigate ASAP.
Ouch.
Wait, should I have...
These are still on, no?
One is at the start.
That's the ghost babble one, right?
Oh, wait.
I think I need to leave this one alone.
I need these guys...
Conscious?
I can't tell.
I don't know if I need these guys alive or not.
You don't need the guys to do the scene.
I don't!
Oh, okay.
Yeah!
Okay.
Hope you're having fun!
At work now!
Oh, Neo Cerberus!
Have a good day at work!
Set the light myself?
Oh, okay.
That's a little tricky.
Wait, it's kind of set.
Thank you.
It has been updated.
Okay.
Nice boss.
Thank you!
I'm gonna put them...
I'm gonna take them out with the...
With our little...
That pistol.
Yup.
Okay.
Nice.
And you.
And we crawl, crawl, crawl...
We crawl, crawl...
Oh.
I'm not close enough.
We crawl, crawl, crawl...
Oh,
you son of a gun.
Don't turn the lines back on!
Come on!
Is he gonna come up here?
You jerk.
You'll pay for this.
Wait, is he coming up here for real?
Oh, I can just get him then.
Oh, nope.
What is he doing?
Oh, he is!
He yelled so...
Fast!
Your reflexes are crazy, mister!
Are you still alive?
Hold on, I forgot to check.
Or I forgot to position these, I think.
Oh no!
Look at that!
I'm such a genius!
They're perfectly positioned.
Gravity takes another.
I...
That was not my fault.
100%.
I gotta get this other guy though.
What else are we...
Hold on, let me...
Get this other guy and then I'll...
He died in his sleep.
He died doing what he loved.
Sleeping.
I'm an...
I am an innocent ghost.
He he he.
I am innocent.
Innocent ghost.
Uh, uh, uh.
Okay, maybe that'll work.
Right?
Go to sleep!
Nice.
You alright?
Oh shoot.
Wait!
I caught you though!
Please fall asleep!
Almost there.
Please fall asleep.
Get up.
Um...
I think I messed up.
Please fall asleep.
Oh.
Oh he noticed.
What the hell is this?
I know, crazy right?
What are you doing?
Oh, you are going to check on him.
I was like, do you hate this guy or something?
Okay.
Oh, holy am.
Is that it?
Yeah, I already recreated that scene.
So we're okay.
Yippee!
If only it were a chaff.
That's another scene recreated.
Okay.
Nice work.
Thank you!
Okay.
Uh...
What else we got?
A soldier?
And a tank?
A soldier and a tank?
And the car!
Oh, we can do the car maybe right now.
I don't...
Yeah, there's nobody up there.
There's only this guy.
I don't think he'll notice.
Probably.
Oh yeah!
Where did I get grenades from?
In here?
Uh...
I wonder if the smoke grenade will work.
I think you can get grenades in any of these, no?
I lied.
Yikes.
Uh...
Armory near...
Armory near the tank!
Okay, okay.
I have smoke grenades, but I don't know if they work as well, you know?
Keys!
What was that, guys?
Pretending to be...
Alright!
Keys!
Almost there.
We also have to do the marking, I just realized.
The Koj...
Or the Kojima one...
Kojima marking is not...
Anything special, maybe?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, get out of the car.
Get out of the car.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Leave.
Leave this place.
Not yet, Snake.
It's not over yet.
Shining light does nothing, huh?
What?!
This is...
What is this?
Landing zone?
Oh, landing zone?
Logo marking area.
Marker placed.
Logo...
There's so many!
Wait, there's so many!
Holy cow!
Weapon.
Like my...
That's...
Okay, hold on.
Marker placed.
Oh, there's one right over here?
Raven.
Oof.
Wait...
Oh!
Touch!
I don't remember if there's a guy up here.
Oh my god, Johnny.
Please.
Johnny, go see a doctor.
Please!
My man.
And then this guy over here.
Okay.
Uh...
You.
Grab him.
Quick!
And drop him.
And...
Hide.
Oh my god.
That was so...
That was so stinking close.
Alright, where was our next marker?
Here?
Or...
Marker placed.
Wait...
I...
Put the...
There we go.
Okay.
Go back to Babel, there's another logo.
Oh, there is?
Okay, I'll go back in a bit.
Oh...
Now that we have...
I don't have very many bullets left, but...
It's better than...
It's better than not having it.
At least since this is quiet.
No, I don't have grenade...
I don't...
I only have...
You guys, I only have smoke grenades.
Oh, what?
What?
I don't have grenades!
When did I get those?
You know what?
I...
Sorry.
I was wrong.
And I am not afraid to admit when I am wrong.
I was...
I was completely wrong.
I...
Completely forgot picking up...
I think I just picked them up out of habit and...
Just didn't think about it.
I...
I admit fault.
Is there somebody up here?
I can't tell.
Maybe not.
Maybe we're okay.
We said some to you in the mail.
So kind of you.
Wait, where's the...
Where's the marker?
Is it up here?
Behind the warning sign.
Oh.
Oopsie.
The warning sign.
It's over here, no?
You picked up a bunch of stuff all at once.
The armory.
Ah!
I see.
What is that one?
Oh!
Two!
That one should disappear.
Oh.
Did you do the main mission already?
I did.
Wait, how do I?
If you want to finish the mission, head for the road.
No, Kaz!
If you want to look for those other scenes, go ahead.
Kaz, I see it!
Metal Gear Solid 2.
Sons of Liberty.
Thank you.
Kaz knows how to read, you guys.
That's so good.
Keep calling.
Metal Gear Solid 2.
Sons of Liberty.
Snake's model was 3800 polygons.
Wow.
What are we now?
Find something to believe in.
And find it for yourself.
If you do, pass it on to the future.
That's not a bad impression.
Metal Gear Solid 2.
Sons of Liberty.
That wasn't a bad impression, I'd say.
Oh.
I can actually start killing people.
Not gonna lie.
Might make the finding of the rest of them easier.
No!
That is not Solid Snake!
Oh.
Ah.
Cause blowing up that one is gonna cause a ruckus.
And he is asleep.
Cause impersonating Iroquois Plissken now.
Cause could never.
Plissken is a perfect being.
Nobody could ever.
Oh.
You see nothing.
Hey.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Do something.
I dare you.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
That's stupid.
Oh.
Uh, you.
Meowp, meowp, meowp, meowp, meowp.
Productions.
Oh, whoops.
Uh, Kojima.
Production.
Okay, keep it that way.
Alright.
How do I get the one behind the...
Nothing.
Oh.
Stop!
Okay.
You have to blow up the sign.
Ah, okay.
Sources.
They'll reveal a lot you couldn't see with the naked eye.
Let's blow it up.
And then we'll get the...
We'll do two...
We'll do two things at once.
Hopefully nobody heard that.
Nobody heard that.
Is that it?
An
explosion.
Damage unknown.
Over.
Nobody heard that.
Do-do-do-doom.
Bop, bop, bop.
They heard that.
Nobody heard it.
No.
It's fine if they heard it.
Oh.
Great.
You recreated every scene.
Now head for the goal.
You can check its location...
Good.
You erased a marking.
Looks like there's more of them.
You might be able to erase the markings, but the memories will never disappear.
Marker placed.
Does that mean...
That's so deep.
Where at?
Where are you?
I'll find it.
Don't tell me.
I found it.
Snake eater.
Wow.
Oh, I should've...
I should've called him first.
Was there a logo here?
I did not see it though.
I didn't see a logo here.
Or was it?
On top of Ghost Babble Shack.
There's one there?
Can I ask if anybody knows how many there are?
Or if anybody cares to Google for me?
How many are there?
So that I can...
So I can be prepared.
Oh, this guy's still asleep.
Awesome.
Five for five games.
Okay, that's what I thought.
There might be.
Seven?
Wait.
Like five that I erase?
Ka's impression of the boss.
Look it up later.
Yeah, I have to.
I want to hear it.
I'm running, running, running, running, running, running.
Oh, that's the one that was over here.
That's right.
It was a touch.
One on top.
Oh, I see!
Wait, is that... That's V?
Haha, ground zeroes.
What do these get me, actually?
I don't even know what I'm doing.
I wish I had the boss's stamina.
I know, right?
Oh, call first!
Sorry, guys.
I get so...
I get so into it.
I'm sorry.
I forgot to ask.
I know.
I forgot.
What?
There are magazines in here the whole time.
Funny.
Oops.
Uh-oh.
I only have six rounds left.
I'll have to go lethal soon.
They stay asleep forever in this game.
It's kind of crazy.
Oh, see?
He's already yawning.
I think they're just not getting enough sleep.
I think they're, like, overworked.
Go back to where Johnny is.
Wait, why?
Oh, I didn't even notice this guy.
I think I killed him before.
Overworked, underpaid.
Yeah, see?
These guys are still asleep.
Like, they stay asleep a long time.
Because it's like, you know...
Oh, sorry.
I pressed one thing.
Goal.
Okay, we know that.
We know that, obviously.
Where's the rest of them?
No!
That's not what I want!
Spit it out!
Useless!
Oh, okay.
Does it strike anybody else?
Odd that nobody is freaked out about having a dart stuck in their body?
Nah, it's probably, like...
Normal.
It's like hazing.
Everybody gets darted.
All the time.
Over by Johnny.
Besides the mobile logo, there's a second on the metal roof.
Oh, thank you!
Back we go!
Oh, oh.
It's a bug.
Okay, Buzz.
Buzz has got to do his little shimmy first.
Yeah, we don't know what types of bugs there are here either.
You know?
It could be some crazy dart bugs.
So, I've done all of them now.
So, on top of this...
Can I even get up here?
How do I get...
Oh, do I have to go on top of...
Ew!
No, no!
Oh!
Can I get on top...
Oh, please.
I'm sorry.
Oh, God.
Oh, here we go.
Yeah, clearly.
Did I...
Did I get one guy?
Did I get one guy just so you can listen to Johnny some more?
Oh, it's under it.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh,
it's original Metal Gear!
Oh, I forgot!
I'm sorry, guys.
I suck.
I'm sorry.
I get so excited.
Oh, she has amnesia.
She hates the codec.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, um...
Can I have a hint where another one would be?
Knock on his door.
Can we?
Yeah, I think...
Four and Peace Walker?
Oh.
I didn't mean it.
Wait, how do I knock, actually?
Oh.
Please don't.
I don't want to...
I don't want to be here anymore.
All erasables are marked on the map.
But...
I checked.
I'll go look.
Oh!
This guy only has two of these left!
Why?
Oh, interesting.
Interesting, interesting.
I like how Snake just climbs over barbed wire.
Not a care in the world.
Oh, I stepped on him.
I did?
I thought the ones here were like the...
The ones that I had gotten.
Oh!
I see it!
I almost did it.
Look.
Boss, head toward the objective.
I almost did it.
Metal Gear 2.
Solid Snake.
Snake was 16 by 32 pixels and eight colors.
Why is he so obsessed with pixel size?
Gosh, guys.
Not everything is about size.
When making decisions on the battlefield, there's no single right answer.
Just trust your own judgment.
Over and out.
As a gamer!
Trust your instincts as a gamer!
Metal Gear 2.
Solid Snake.
Snake was 16 by 32 pixels.
Nice work!
Okay, cool.
And then...
I could have sworn I thought these ones were like the...
Oops.
Uh, were like the...
Ghost babbles and the ones that I had seen and couldn't do.
So, thank you.
Can I not?
I can't erase it.
I thought you could.
Okay, over here.
On the roof?
Oh, wait!
Oh, I see it!
Wait, there's two of them!
Metal Gear...
Huh.
What's that?
Metal Gear...
Huh?
Metal Gear Solid 4.
Guns of the Patriots.
How many pixels was Snake this time?
Or polygons, I guess.
Snake's model was 14,000 polygons.
Ha!
Woo-ah!
Ah!
Wait, what do you mean?
Wait, how do you know?
Wait!
What?
Liquid!
I like how that one's orange.
Why?
Wait...
What did it trigger, though?
Go loud?
Yeah, baby.
Maybe...
Check the eye droid?
Can I leave, or is there something else that I should...
Do?
Someone woke up!
You can leave?
Peace Walker left, but he said, um...
I like how there's so many magazines.
You said that was the last one.
Want a hint for Peace Walker?
Oh, yes, please.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That would be great.
Check the orange lie.
Oh!
Oh, oh.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
I did not see this man.
I did not...
I did, sorry.
Sorry.
Wait!
How did he survive?
Shit.
Oh, I can't get him.
I can't get him.
Oh, shit.
I'm so...
No!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just kill him.
No, please.
I'm innocent.
I wasn't trying to kill anybody.
I wasn't.
I see the fox logo right there.
I see it.
Don't forget about me.
He'll forget about me.
That was a super good run, though.
I know!
We were so close!
He'll come up, and then I'll get his ass.
Where is he, actually?
Oh, here he comes.
Nice.
Stay down!
Ah!
Are you for real?
Get out of there.
You get out of here.
You get out of there.
Time to make a pile.
You go.
This guy's snoring below me.
He almost came up here, and then didn't.
You're so slow.
Come on!
Do something!
Nice!
Okay.
Now I can do what I wanted to do.
Wait.
I hear him.
I don't know where he is!
I hear him!
But I don't know...
I hear you!
That guy sounded so close!
Maybe it was him.
Anyway.
Uh...
Oh!
Ah!
The dance!
Well, I'll be.
Kojima Productions, LA.
LA?
Well, I'll be.
How quirky.
Oh, thanks.
Sorry.
My one casualty.
Maybe more.
I don't remember.
Is that it, then?
Am I done?
Oh, call?
The enemy's searching for you.
Stay out of sight.
Still got the...
Okay.
Yeah.
Where's the Peace Walker logo, everybody?
Please help.
Call the chopper.
Oh, look.
My bad one.
Uh...
I could call him here.
Wait, can I actually?
On the chopper?
No.
Danger low?
How?
How is this...
How can he land here?
Actually, I'm very confused.
I'm working on it.
Okay, he doesn't care about Kojima Productions.
He's a hater.
He just lands there.
But how?
It's so...
There's not any space here at all.
Morpho!
It's on the chopper.
Got it.
Do I...
Board the chopper?
Or do I...
Um...
What?
This was supposed to be low!
This is Morpho.
On station at LC.
Do not board.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thanks guys.
Oh my god.
Uh...
I'm looking.
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Wait, does that count?
Actually?
Nope.
Uh...
Other side?
Ah!
There it is!
Oh, he hates it!
Ah!
Nevermind.
I can't stand this man!
The markings...
That every one of them will always...
Ha ha!
Cute!
Target acquired!
In hot!
Um...
You can leave now, Morpho!
Might even be better for you, buddy.
Oh, what?!
How did that not hit?
This is Morpho.
On station at LC.
Death Stranding week.
Yeah, it was actually supposed to be...
CP, this is Delta IV.
Murder explosion.
Location is clear.
It was right behind you!
Oh!
Oops.
Oopsie.
I thought that was my other...
Oh!
Oops!
I have two deaths on my hands.
I am not an innocent man.
I haven't...
Where?
Where?!
Oh, shit.
In hot!
They had a kill,
Morpho.
No targets remaining.
Ending attack run and we'll stand by at LC.
Okay!
This is Morpho.
Have arrived at LC.
We'll stand by.
Bye!
Oh, look.
Those mice are Alaskan field mice.
But there are no mice.
No.
No, they're not.
Guys, your meds.
Are you feeling okay?
Yeah!
Phew.
At least you made it out in one piece.
I know.
Minus nine, nine, nine, nine for my time.
I was just like, I can do this quickly!
Nearly an hour later.
Ouch!
Not yet, Snake!
It's not over yet!
You really didn't count the Trank guy who fell.
Yeah!
Impressive work, Snake.
Mission complete.
Is not what I'm here to say.
Oh.
Believe it or not, the real mission starts here.
Oh!
Huh?
I'm scared!
This is not Master Miller!
Snake, you're too late.
It's me!
Dear brother!
Woo!
I'm gonna ask you some questions about Metal Gear Solid 1.
Okay.
If you answer all of them correctly, then and only then, do you truly clear this mission.
I'm scared!
It's pressure!
I'll even throw in a special bonus.
Woo!
Huh?
You didn't think you made it this far by yourself, did you?
But you'll have to solve the rest of this riddle yourself.
These impressions are killing me.
Wow!
Woo!
The difficulty level is normal.
Normal, okay.
Get just one question wrong, and the mission is over.
Okay.
There are no continues, my friend.
Don't even think about looking up the answers online.
Or I know.
Oh!
Ready?
Okay.
Take the Metal Gear Solid quiz?
Yes.
Here we go.
Snake!
These are so funny.
Funny!
Oh!
MGS1 featured Solid Snake infiltrating which island?
Wow!
There's so many questions!
Oh my gosh!
Okay.
Shadow Moses.
Correct.
Tweedoo!
Hawaii.
The remote-controlled missile was known by which nickname?
Nikita!
Natasha!
Katherine!
Nikita!
Correct.
Question?
Who did you need to call on the codec in order to save your progress?
Oh!
This is a trick question if you were thinking of two, right?
Meilin!
Correct.
You're pretty good.
Question?
Oh no!
I'm becoming stupid!
The Next Generation Special Forces who took part in the uprising with Foxhound were given what treatment?
They might as well have been lobotomies!
That's so good!
Correct.
Question?
Um, wait.
Actually, I have a sound...
Hold on, wait.
I have a sound on my soundboard that sounds like this too.
Nope, not that one.
Oh my god, it's so loud!
Wait, hold on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that one!
Haha!
Badum!
On which floor of the nuclear warhead storage building was Otacon's lab located?
Bottom of a trap pit!
Third floor?
Or second floor?
Oh god, it's a...
Second floor basement?
I can't remember!
I can't remember numbers!
I don't even think about asking chat.
It's a second floor basement.
Don't look it up.
I'm not.
I'm using you guys for help.
Third was the back...
Gas room.
I always mix them up which was which.
Correct.
Question.
What was Cyborg Ninja's true identity?
Wait, this is awesome!
This is also a trick question!
That's messed up.
The fact that it's Frank Hunter.
No way!
That's so messed up!
Correct.
Question.
Before being called back into action for the mission, Snake lived in Alaska as a what?
A musher!
An ear pull competitor?
Okay.
What does that even mean?
I'm glad you remember.
Of course!
That's my favorite!
That's like actually one of my favorite things.
Wait.
What was the maximum load of the elevator in communications tower B?
300 kilograms?
30 ravens?
Does 30 ravens equate to 5 or 4 people?
It's 4 people.
Is that about 30 ravens?
It's so funny.
300 kilograms, right?
Yeah.
650 pounds would be like 4 people.
Average.
Raven mentions ear pulling as a warrior game.
Oh, that's right!
Correct.
Okay.
If you think you'll get the answer out of me, forget it.
There isn't even any sodium pentothal here.
Question.
These like people in the background that are giggling and stuff.
Which type of storage media did the arms tech president give Snake?
Optical disc.
Punch card.
It's the optical disc, right?
Yeah.
Correct.
You got quite a memory.
Thank you.
Now for the final question.
Let's finish this.
Have at you, Snake.
Question.
Punch cards is so funny.
What is the title of the ending theme?
Oh, wow.
If you didn't know, this is kind of messed up though.
Because it's all of them.
The best is yet to come.
I wonder though, what the hard quiz is like now.
Yay!
The only one I really needed help with was the basement one.
Thanks, guys.
I'll give you that special bonus I promise later.
Something to look forward to.
I enjoyed it myself.
Master Miller.
Thank you.
Engine!
Hound!
Alive!
Yay!
This is so goofy.
Just what I'd expect from a man with the same coat as the boss.
Yay!
What did I get?
Oh!
Just loaded?
Yay!
Now, I have a question.
If I do this...
If I do this mission again, will they be the Shadow Moses?
Will they be the Shadow Moses?
Uh...
The soldiers as well.
Or is it only in hard mode?
After hard mode!
Oh, I have to do hard mode too.
If you beat it on hard.
Ah!
I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see.
If you press right...
Oh!
This...
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Wait a second.
Okay, I'm not gonna actually do the mission.
I said that last time too.
But I actually, I do wanna see you though.
I wanna see you though.
You've proven your MGS nerdiness supremacy.
I must say boss, you're pretty good.
Thank you.
I felt like most of them were too easy though, no?
I still think the Frank Hunter thing is kinda messed up.
That's actually pretty messed up.
Oh my gosh, it's...
Snowing!
There's a different quiz on hard mode.
Oh, is there a different quiz on hard mode?
There is, there is.
Actually, can we look it up?
I wanna see what it is.
Hard quiz is actually hard?
Let's try it.
Well, I'm not gonna do it.
But, you know, I'm gonna try it.
Kept you waiting, huh?
Okay, that's...
No.
This is so wrong.
No!
No, I hate it!
I hate it!
He never got cause to meow at you in his date.
That's true.
But also, no, I'm not redoing missions.
I'm just...
This is so great!
I just wanna show you guys the, uh...
The soldiers.
Look, look, look, look, look!
He's so cute!
I love...
I love the gnome soldiers!
And it's snowing!
This is so awesome!
Look, look, look, look, look!
Look, look, look!
Oh my god, they're so cute!
As usual, this is a one-man infiltration mission.
Weapons and equipment...
This is a one-man infiltration mission.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let me...
Let me leave.
Huh?
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it, buddy.
Oh wait...
What can we put on?
It's kinda owned, actually.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah!
Oh god, I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die!
Run!
I'm just running!
I'm being alive, actually!
Oh my god!
Come here!
No!
Do do do do do!
Do do do do!
Do do do2!
Give her that!
That was good.
Return to the sea!
Wow, perfect way to end it.
I'll be honest.
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
I did not mean to put on this song.
There we go.
I don't know when I will start five.
Might be once I get back from Japan.
So... In a whole month, probably.
But, yeah.
Probably sometime before I start it.
What about Death Stranding?
Oh, I was saying that!
Actually, this month I wanted to do the Death Stranding week.
But, might have to wait until next month.
I had some other stuff that was, like, coming up and other obligations and things and things.
So... But I don't go to Japan until... Until... End of May.
So... We have lots of time.
Guys would be really happy to know you're going to Japan.
I know!
We'll wait for you guys.
Thank you!
Yeah.
But I have to... Finish Death Stranding as quickly as I can because... When does that come out?
Hold on, let me check.
Let's see.
Lambda, thank you!
Death Stranding!
Rawr!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, Lambda, you... Your wallet, please!
Your wallet, please!
Death Stranding...
This is so nostalgic.
Right?
I love this version so much.
Oh, so thank you for the brand!
Thank you for the brand!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
I saw that someone uploaded a mint poster for the cardboard box!
No way!
Really?
We might have to do... I want to play 5 with a bunch of mods.
I'll be honest.
It might make the game go a little bit faster, so...
Um... Which is not a problem for me.
I've already played it.
Uh... Ducky, thanks for the gift!
Ducky!
Ducky, thank you for the 5 gift!
Thank you!
So...
Um...
Yeah, yeah, yeah... Oh!
This is an AI overview.
I don't know if I could trust that.
Oh!
June 26th!
So late June!
Wait, June 26th?
I might have to play it once I'm back from Japan my second trip.
Yeah, I'm going to Japan twice in June, you guys.
It's a...
It's a little... It's a little... It's a little, yeah.
And it's not for, like, idle things or anything like that.
It's actually all work.
In fact, I thought I would have only three recordings on my trip coming up in May.
But I actually added, potentially, a new one.
So that's four recordings.
Of exciting things.
So, honestly, I'm making the most out of that trip.
Like a crazy amount.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can't wait to see what you've been cooking.
I hope you guys will like everything.
It's been hard work, but hopefully it all pays out.
It all works out.
It pays off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But, yeah.
Work's off.
All pays work.
Yeah, and then August 23rd.
MGS Con.
And we have...
Delta.
I think, actually, it's just a couple days after.
No?
Proud of you, Mito.
Oh, thank you.
Mito Airlines sponsor win.
Oh, my poor wallet.
Like three days.
Yeah.
Especially, I got the...
Of course...
Of course, I had to get the early edition.
So...
I will be playing mine a couple days early.
I'm watching him stream this game.
Oh, thank you, Salmi.
Thank you for the raid, too.
I appreciate it so much.
Well, I actually am...
This was it for Ground Zeroes.
I did everything I wanted to do, too.
I'm really happy with it.
We did the main mission.
We did the Kojima mission.
We did the Raiden mission.
And we did Deja Vu even twice.
And we got to see the cute little genome soldiers walking around.
Yeah.
Oh, yes.
Let's try the hard quiz.
I'm just going to look it up, though.
I hope you guys don't mind.
Hold on.
Metal Gear Ground Zeroes...
Hard quiz.
I'll read you the questions and...
The...
What the...
Oh, wait.
Don't...
Oh, this is normal.
Okay.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
This one has the answers right below it.
IGN, why would you do that?
Um...
Matty!
Thank you so much for the dead gift.
Thank you!
Is that...
I've been wondering.
Is your profile picture...
Like...
Venom Suwako?
Do a YouTube video?
Let me see.
Oh, yeah.
I guess we can do the YouTube video...
Because I want to hear what it sounds like.
What's it called?
Oh.
Metal Gear...
Ground Zeroes...
Quiz card.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
This is an IGN video.
They're gonna...
They're gonna copyright strike me.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna pause the music.
Uh...
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do...
Oh, here we go.
You know what?
Hold on.
Let me make sure this doesn't have, like, somebody talking.
It's only two minutes.
Let me make sure it's not someone... speaking of... Okay.
Okay.
All right.
I will... hold on.
I will screen share... or window capture, I mean.
Screen share, like I'm on Discord.
Oh, ground zero squeeze hard.
I'll keep the person in whose video I'm using.
Let me make sure... hold on.
Let me get... let me crop it a little.
I couldn't see it.
It was too small.
There we go.
Okay.
Thanks, Refusio.
Thank you.
All right.
I can't turn off the game, so sorry.
We'll just have that ambiance.
Oh.
Okay.
Wow.
Snack!
I'm gonna pause it.
Question one.
Okay.
What did Snake call Otakon's love for a certain female character?
Uh, Stockholm Syndrome.
Towards Sniper Wolf, no?
Oh!
No audio!
So sorry.
Thank you.
Stockholm Syndrome.
Yeah!
When Otakon visited Snake...
...at his cell after he was captured, he gave...
...him Sniper Wolf's handkerchief...
...rations, ketchup, and which level of security card?
...infinity?
Was it six?
There is no level 10.
Six?
I'm not looking at chat.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
I'm not looking at chat this time, though.
Oh!
Which boss character was not a member of the newly formed Foxhound unit?
Boss character?
Uh...
Cyborg Ninja?
Ah!
I always forget he's a boss.
What...
Oh my gosh.
What was the name of the studio later named to Kojima Productions at...
Oh!
Ah!
I don't know.
K...
Well, I guess it's not KCE Tokyo.
Sorry.
I'm not fast enough.
KCE Japan?
I would've said Tokyo.
Wait.
Maybe it's Konami Tech Development Center.
Oh!
No!
I was right!
KCE Japan!
Oh my gosh.
I would've...
I would've second-guessed myself.
Oh my god.
I would've also probably guessed Tokyo.
Right!
Oh!
It's in the opening.
Ah!
That one's tough.
Yeah.
You're pretty good.
Can you hear it okay?
Oh my god!
Well, this one is so easy.
In MGS1, who did Autocon fall in love with?
This one!
He went so fast!
Well, I totally would've gotten Sniper Wolf easy.
Naomi Hunter.
That's disgusting.
Okay.
Question.
Johnny Sasaki ended up unconscious and unclothed outside the holding cell.
In the Japanese version, he wore boxer shorts to hide his private parts.
How were they hidden in the Western version?
He was naked, baby!
He was pixelized!
It was pixelization.
Yeah!
We got that.
Oh!
Why are you glad that I remember that?
Covered with straw is so funny.
Snake attempted to give Meryl a handgun of which caliber?
Oh!
I...
Uh...
45?
Was it 45?
Oh my god!
I might be...
I might actually be good at this.
Oh my god!
After escaping the base, Snake and Meryl encountered a family of which animal?
The caribou!
I do.
Sorry, it's so quiet.
But they're saying the same thing as before.
Question.
In total, how many prototypes were made of the stealth camouflage Otacon developed?
Five!
Correct.
Now for the final question.
Let's finish this.
Have at you, Snake.
Oh!
What did the PAL and PAL key signify?
Permissive action link?
Oh my god!
I wouldn't...
I'll...
Most of these though!
The ones that I'm second guessing on, I would not have gotten without the multiple choice.
Oh my god!
I wouldn't have gotten...
I wouldn't have gotten that without it giving me the option.
Yeah!
Excellent job!
Thank you!
But there are no more special bonuses.
Which makes me wonder...
Why are you here then?
Why do you continue to answer questions while your memory betrays you?
You enjoy taking quizzes!
I almost spat out my drink!
Engine!
Difficulty is my first time on this too.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Don't look at my recommended.
Fox!
Yeah, Nimi is streaming right now.
And we will raid into her.
We will raid into her.
So...
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you for Ground Zeroes.
Like I said, it'll be a little bit before we do five.
But...
But yeah!
This is a lot of fun.
And...
I love this game.
It's so fun to just...
You know...
Who knows she watches videos!
I'm embarrassed by when I watch them.
Um...
Yeah...
So...
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
And I will see you guys...
Uh...
When I see you next!
Happy...
Uh...
East!
Atsumito!
I!
More questions...
Vocals...
Hinted!
Bye-bye!